une production du studio sfr nous sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut que nos invités date site super h
quand moi donc pas fallu aller la gagne
le podcast aujourd'hui présentée par nos
amis chez terriens terriens c'est une un
bureau de comptable ça fait plus de 25
ans qui existent sont spécialisés dans
les pme de 1 à 100 employés ma mère me
donnait une leçon parce qu'il trouvait
que je vais en a 100 employés choisi une
liaison avec le s mais c'est un à 100
employés fait voilà ma venger j'ai
corrigé le problème dit il travaille
dans le fond avec des compagnies
d'avenir c'est à dire multimédia jeux
vidéo studio de podcasts nous on fait
affaire avec eux je n'allais pas avoir
besoin de leur expliquer votre modèle
d'affaires parce qu'ils sont habitués
dans ce genre de domaine là ils vont
vous aider à maximiser votre retour de
crédit d'impôt recherche et
développement cedeao et multimédia puis
en plus il offre un système
d'impartition comptable c'est à dire
qu'il devienne votre département de
comptabilité à l'intérieur de votre
entreprise pour des frais qui sont très
raisonnables pour une pme fait que
appelées pm10 la con
qu'on leur dit ça lui en fait puis merci
beaucoup et rien que ce n'était rien
nous encourager comme cette semaine
cette semaine ph dominique plancke
cette semaine dominique plancke pascal
hugo à s'est révélé son vrai nom cette
semaine on a reçu 1 go j'étais très
content de rencontrer s'appelle fred
st-gelais est un musicien fait la même
éthique - fax à maurice à me toucher
parce que l'armée musicien guitariste et
réalisateur surtout de musique
plusieurs reconnaissent vous le
connaissez sans doute parce que entre
autres pour sa longue relation de
travail et amoureuse avec une certaine
marie me vous êtes peut-être de ton
entendu parler mais également d'autres
artistes comme marc dupré et plus
récemment les deux bourgeois et
plusieurs autres un gars très talentueux
dans ce qu'il fait est très généreux de
son savoir parce que moi j'ai il m'a
donné beaucoup de jus musica j'ai
vraiment tripé j'espère que vous allez
messieurs autant que nous un gossip que
qui vit très simplement de simplicité
volontaire qui est qui le strict minimum
pour faire ce que besoin pour travailler
pour bien vivre et ultime en être
heureux dans la simplicité
pardon un chat dans la gorge oui les
plans un goût aussi qui est parti faire
un long voyage dans sa vanne qu'il passe
un petit peu plus difficile ou qui
étaient tannés de la musique
et moi je pars en voyage fait le tour
des états unis pour une grande recherche
de connaissance de soi passe à paris
parce que c'est un gars ça se passe ça
paraît que qui est bien qu'ils aient
grandement kiki qui prend le temps de
vivre qui pendant trente ans de respirer
pour tous travailler travailler
travailler comme il y avait longtemps
dans sa vie ben je raconterai pas tout
bas de casse vous découvrez faire pour
vous autres mais un pas de casse aussi
comment les deux musiciens auraient pu
tomber un peu plus plus deep comme on
dit dans le
dans le monde la musique puis des termes
un peu plus technique mais je pense que
c'est accessible pour tous je pense que
vous allez vraiment aimé ça c'est je
pense que c'est très intéressant de
connaître d'apercevoir un peu c'est que
les dessous de deux mondes à musique
comment ça c'était un album commence à
se faire une toune commence à marcher en
studio tout se précise les super gentil
c'est pas généreux ouais c'est ça paraît
quand on parle à quelqu'un qui est bien
dans sa vie
quelqu'un qui quitte à l'aise qui est
rendu à un endroit qui est heureux ça ça
transparaît puis on est capable de le
percevoir dans une conversation comme se
retrouver l'amour offrir - il retrouvé
l'amour avec notre invité d'honneur sous
podcast kim gingras
c'était c'est vraiment une super
rencontre avec fred et profitez en et
écoutez la parlez-en à vos amis laissez
des commentaires aussi la campagne pour
que john mayer occupation 2 bat son
plein m continuez à commenter l'état
m'zab dans les airs la description pour
inciter d'hommes à s'inscrire
d'accordage et moi pas on va l'avoir
sinon abonnez vous à nos chaînes puis e
puis on vous aime tous bon voyage est
bon pas de casse bonne écoute
[Musique]
tiens je laisse à lui et grâce à vous ça
va très bien vous même très bien merci
d'être là notre dame en blanc certains
quand le merci pour l'invitation
tu étais entré ici puis on a tout pris
des conseils des techniques sonores
c'est rare que souvent le monde devine
si ils font comme c'est beau la vie vous
êtes bien installés tout au regard des
pressions je pense ma viennent à l'avant
des pythons a viré débutante
bon c'est pas grave certains députés
oui c'est ça d'habitants plus de la
rocade aux mères d'enfants le ta job le
pauvre pour que le monde comprenne que
ce fait c'est quoi une stérilité des
réalisateurs d'affronter ouais surtout s
comme celui d'être décrit je sais pas où
je pense que oui mais dans ma demande ne
passe pas il marque et musiciens
musiciens réussi c'est parce que dans ma
tête il n'y a rien d'autre qui serait
arrivé si ça n'avait pas été de la
musique fait de jouer la musique à la
base pour la musique mais il ya beaucoup
de monde qui se demande c'est quoi un
réalisateur
par ailleurs c'est pas clair il y en a
qui réalise des films y en a qui
réalisent des disques oui c'est vraiment
une job indifférente
puis moi même j'avais posté quoi quand
j'étais jeune je me rappelle que moi
j'ai grandi des années 80 la mode c'est
les grands cheveux longs pieds gosses
maquiller motlik robben joue vite c'est
colin ouais je tripais sur la musique je
pratique la guitare dix ans par jour
mais l'idée de maquiller de porter des
collants ce n'était pas tant que ça mon
bac
ouais puis je me disais ah ça va
peut-être un mal nécessaire si je vais
être musicien
je regardais les pochettes d'album à
l'époque pie je voyais toujours tes
produced by b20 nom s'est réalisée par
qui avait dénombré elsa temps mais je me
rendais compte que le réalisateur est
souvent hilco écrivaient les chansons
avec l'artiste
il joue à plein d'instruments sur
l'album visaient des arrangements
je me rappelle je vais demander mon prof
de guitare martin larose on le salue
c'est qu'ils sortent vraiment garder je
pense pas qu'ils donnent des cours mais
un studio d'enregistrement saguenay
d'accord superactif grande influence
positive dans la vie d'un musicien puis
dans ma vie tout court
je me souviens du nord demandé c'est
quoi ce produced by lui m'avait dit
souvent ça c'est le réalisateur lui
c'est un musicien qui souvent peu plus
d'expérience puisqu'il veut pas
nécessairement faire des tournées mais
mais qui écrit des chansons avec y est
en studio avec le groupe iliad
les artistes à donner leur meilleur
potentiel l'écrire les maires chansons
possibles puis a donné la meilleure
performance en studio moi je me rappelle
c'est fait comme moi dans ma tête c'est
comme waouh ça existe pouvoir gagner sa
vie que la musique sens les cheveux
maquillage faire la guide donne ce stage
avec des collants faite depuis ce temps
j'ai dit moi je ne savais pas trop ce
que ça fait c'est quoi
mais je savais que c'était si je le fais
je savais que tu serais pas le goal
frontman en avant un kiwi la patente se
savait déjà
j'avais déjà dit et cgt dans des bennes
j'étais chanteur dans des bennes pour le
fun pipeau à prendre le plus de choses
possibles sur le métier
tout ça ça m'intéresse ça n'intéresse
chanter jouer la guitare jeudi tous les
instruments à écrire des chansons est un
studio tout m'intéresse fait que c'est
important pour moi même de comprendre la
réalité de l'artiste et c'était juste un
geek de studios plutôt aucune idée de ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire rendre lâche
la chanson en spectacle c'est difficile
d'arriver d'aiguillés l'artiste à savoir
comment faire là tout d'un studio
alors que cit a l'expérience du
spectacle l'expérience de la sas
qu'évoque allemand séquences choisies la
tonalité dans lesquelles tout l'artiste
va chanter la tonne faut que tu penses à
c'est peut-être que ça sonne bien super
aiguë pendant que le champ
s'égosille mais quand s'il va faire
trois soirs par semaine pendant deux ans
et demi j français qui est capable de
chanter
soir après soir en fait que c'est des
décisions qui sont en partie sa sas et
c'est toujours dans ton dans ton
raisonnement quand tu produis une
chanson de dire c'est quoi la
faisabilité cette chanson-là vincent
nichols ouest en équilibre c'est sûr
qu'il ya d'autres outils très souvent
par juste une chanson si une chanson va
être vraiment plus efficace chanter
vraiment au cd fois la focus entre la
douleur dans la performance vocale
il faut faut la mettre à une certaine
hauteur que le chanteur travaille fort
pour la rendre mais le compromis ça peut
être bon à la baisse un petit peu un
spectacle ouais ça va la faire un ton
plus beau pour que ce soit un petit peu
plus facile à faire mais mais c'est
toujours important de garder ça à
l'esprit chez titre doivent s'absenter
dit m absolument notre avance m
mais puisque le soleil était chanteur
dans des bennes de meta genre avant de
voir la réalité
pis il dit que me dis moi ça me sert
foule d'être chanteur parce que chute
avec kitty purry où je travaillais
qu'une tel ou tel ou untel ses piles
utilisées layton pour tout les clips
graët tout les artistes et les jeunes et
les autres mais ils capables de faire
fait le plus de même fidèle fierté de
faire l'exemple
tandis qu'il a démontrées cessé de
démontrer moi je comprends pas comment
tu peux qu écrire des chansons pour
réaliser des chansons sans écrire
chanter pantoute
- je comprends pas mais il y en a qui le
font en fait que la brique robben
réalise des dix piges et judo qu'un
instrument
factea la beauté de ça c'est que c'est
pour ça que c'est si difficile de
définir définir ce métier là c'est qu'il
ya mille et une façon de l'exercer puis
il ya personne qui fait la même façon
theillet des réalisateurs comme rick
rubin justement qui a réalisé slayer
dans les dixie chicks kanye west kanye
west réalisées dans ses bottes ch
butch vig nirvana aussi dans mon top 5
médecins pour en revenir
il joue d'aucun instrument n'y a jamais
qu'une chanson de sa vie il chante pas
mais il se définit lui-même comme un fan
de musique professionnelle
c'est son seul ce qui est sa seule
habileté c'est de savoir quand c'est bon
c'est la mode du goûter wang avec lui il
dit on va engager de l'ingénieur tel
batteur on va aller dans tel studio je
vais vous faire écrire détourne avec tel
est l auteur compositeur il comprend
l'artiste y comprend la musique que
l'artiste fait il ya comme une façon de
distiller les influences de l'artiste
puis il ya un du science à savoir où est
ce que l'artiste devrait aller à ce
moment là dans sa carrière puis capable
de mettre en place une équipe qui va et
qui détonne avec eux les enregistrer qui
va jouer sur le disque
alors que d'autres réalisateurs comme
axe morton par exemple ou comme ou comme
moi loin de moi l'idée de me mettre dans
à leur niveau mais au niveau de la façon
dont on travaille moi j'étais inspiré
plus tôt par cette génération là qui
s'enferme avec l'artiste dans un studio
puis co écrit les chansons qu'ils vont
jouer plusieurs sinon toutes les
instruments qui vont s'occuper de
l'enregistrement qui vont être ingénieur
c'est moi c'est plus ma façon de faire
un peu par nécessité si je me suis
jamais dit moi je veux frère tout c'est
juste que tu caches ta outil mis dans
mon sous-sol du japon nissan pour
engager drummer puis engager un
claviériste bien flèche de m'organiser
avec mes troupes n'ont pas de calais qui
s'est mis dans mon sous-sol commencé en
secondaire 3 défaites enregistrées des
affaires j'écrivais des toons à partir
du moment où mon prof docteur martin
larose liés sur instagram mis partout
cibles commerciales martin larose qui
m'expliquait c'est quoi un réalisateur
c'est comme moi j'aurai ma piste là
j'avais manifesté comme ses soeurs
beaux-frères fait que j'ai commencé à
lire sur le sujet puis à poser toutes
les questions possibles puis à trouver
mes réalisateurs favorite si je me
rendais compte en regardant les
pochettes d'albums y avait des noms qui
revenait moins que des noms qui revenait
piqué même au québec il y avait des noms
comme tino izzo qui qui est encore à mon
avis le meilleur réalisateur québécois
de l'histoire du québec en fait j'ai
travaillé sur quoi il ya fait à l'époque
leur voisine france d'amour
saisir céline dion il a tout fait pour
essayer super fins pire sécheresse
jamais meilleur que lui dis dans ma tête
mon goût roule
ouais mais si j'avais des noms qui
revenait trop temps des réalisateurs
québécois rrq qu'à l'international puis
je les étudier j'écoutais les albums
puis je me rendais compte de leurs
rapports de reconnaître la signature
ben oui c'est d'écouter développeurs
depuis shania twain tentant d'aller avec
75 voix on veut des bébés des gros drom
com comment ça se fait qu'il y ait
autant de points en commun entre eux
nightwing des flippers le titre garde ma
pochette c'est le même gars qui écrit
thoune ce même cas que réalisé l'album
s'est fait que ça a été mon école ces
maladies
tout était petite chute puis ce que tu
t'en aller chercher ta guerre où il
venait que des billets valides et bien
j'ai des musées koussa jean piat - puis
à l'époque il ressemble d'achat avec un
petit magasin de musique qui s'appelait
le comptoir musicale gaudreault avec
toutes mes premiers instruments savais
que je les ai achetées puis d'ailleurs
martin larose et on va juste parler
était vendeur fait l'huile qui a été
d'une influence incroyable dans la vie
c'est que même quand j'ai choisi mes
premières guitares mes premières [ __ ]
de distorsion
j'arrive avec mes cassettes puis juste
eu son lot lui mettez ça dans le player
dans le magasin peut s'attendre à une
distorsion avec beaucoup de bien je vote
en face à une coupe c'est vraiment à ce
point-là fait que salies 3 magasins qui
s'est mis jean pierre puis qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui est écoutée qu'est ce qui
te faisait triper lot avec et là je me
trompe quand oeil cette espèce de déclic
l'espèce de ce jeu fort je pense je
devais c'est quoi quels enjeux touchant
secondaire 4 5
c'est dans ce but là j'étais moche que
pratiqué mais qui tend à 10 ans par jour
un peu plus tôt le matin avant d'aller à
l'école parce que deux ans j'allais à
l'école je reste à l'écouté de l'école
fait que je n'ai pratiquement 45 minutes
ce soir du dîner le soir je faisais
jamais aucun devoir jeu
jusqu'à 9 10 ans qu'est-ce que tu
pratiques et à ce moment là n'importe
quoi tout mais c'était vraiment du rock
c'est là on parle fin des années 80 je
n'y avais pas une tonne qui jouait radio
qui n'est pas sur une telle affaire la
plus pop michael jackson debbie gibson
whoopy il y avait le même site un trader
dirait quelqu'un qui serait dedans à
l'époque d'affectif c'était ce niveau le
niveau minimum en tant que guitariste
s'était pas capable d'avaler les
quadruples accroche comme vannes et l'on
ne peut juste pas être engagée pour
faire quoi que ce soit texter soit c'est
joe satriani steve hay toutes les bonnes
mains dans les mains comme pancho villa
qui était superbe à borgo les solos de
guitare est koch vrai que tu pratiques
vraiment comme un acharné jusqu'à ce que
nirvana inexact c'est ce que les examens
parce qu'il y ait vraiment eu cet
excellent article ziti c'est un peu
ridicule quand c'est quasiment illégal
sortir un tout savoir du trading
ça faisait comme avoir fait le tour des
questions pas plus maintenant mais non
on écoute et les tournées ces années
neuf séquences pourquoi et pourquoi je
me fais ok la gueule systématiquement et
que moi tant qu'à moi je t'avais un
comptable
c'est ce que moi j'ai été élevé à cette
diète le fait que j'aime encore sauf
j'ai encore mes triples une fois par
année
d'habitude à ma femme je me je m'ouvre
une bouteille de tequila puis je mens
temps avec ma guitare de bo d'un salon
pigeât shwed toute la journée jusqu'à
pas que la peau des doigts commencent à
arracher fixé sur gazmont instagram je
pense qu'il ya deux ans j'ai fait des
petits story mais des postes les
dépenses d'une strate rouge la plus
chouette par dessus des tonnes de
satriani pi2 motlik look décalé contre
les curés quand tu cours est arrivé avec
nirvana tout fait y est tout à fait
arc joueurs ils savent pas jouer c'est
que tu vois moi j'ai fait part qu'ils
savent pas jouer ce à quoi ce mardi et
qui initialement ça a été ma réaction
puis le 10 compris à manet ou d'un oui
oui mais pas sur le coup c'est parce que
jamais content
ce qui est encore et encore amer non non
mais c'est parce que tu sais moi je t'ai
faut que tu te ramène en 1991 et en
secondaire 5
nirvana arrive mais moi ça fait depuis
que secondaire 2 que je pratique dix ans
par jour par sera obligatoire d'être
capable de faire tout petit et prouesses
là sur la quittance en train de me dire
que je peux fossé puis gratitude car oui
t'es fait que ces drogues qui mangeait
comme un peu abandonné leur rock
à cette époque là moi j'écoute est juste
du roi où pratiquement juste du rock
jusqu'à ce que la vague grunge arrive
piger comme était frustré du rock pis un
peu c'est sûr que tu es better qu'un
suivi une prépa c'est cet avis est
pratiqué par jour qui a tout d'un coup
spicules pente et avancer dans mon
esprit que j'ai commencé à écouter de la
musique j'ai commencé à trouver ses
harmonies vocales puis commencer à
écouter autre chose que la guitare dans
lyndon commencé à écouter des affaires -
rock groove de baisse dans les vieilles
tôles motown
wouah l'étendue situe au niveau de la
réalisation passé les années 80 ce faire
que tout soit le plus gros poste
le river la compression public où tout
était super bright phi phi la comprendre
un peu la subtilité puis les au style de
musique c'est vraiment là tu sais quand
j'ai commencé à me dégager du rock que
j'ai ouvert la porte a tellement de
styles de la musique qui sont venues
alimenter mon vocabulaire
puis qui tout d'un coup faisait que que
j'ouvrais mon esprit puis que j'étais
plus polyvalent tout d'un coup ci je me
suis dit ok c'est cool je les dents d'un
douanes faire jouer un peu n'importe
quoi parce qu'au niveau technique
si je capable de jouer n'importe quoi
mais mais est-ce que je l'entends dans
ma tête
autre chose que le rot way festival j'ai
commencé coûté des afars puis il ya des
jeunes qui me faisait je me rappelle la
première fois j'ai entendu le le premier
album de garbage il n'y aurait pas de
solo mais il y avait des grosses
guitares quand même mais y avait toutes
sortes de son glaive et jamais entendu
dire et parce que bon le propose le
logiciel pro tools est arrivé qu'il y
avait
tellement de possibilités avec les
ordinateurs de pouvoir manipuler le son
d'une façon qui était pas possible avant
ce qui moi ça l'a vraiment c'est là que
j'ai commencé à m'acheter des synthés
des ventes de programmation de drame
puis de saintes et puis d un pédiatre
qui toutes les leçons qu érik guay qui
avait pas dans la musique que j'écoutais
avant pitstop vraiment partir de ce
moment là où je pense j'ai fait la
transition en guitariste qui veut qui
veut éventuellement peut-être écrire
d'eton puis faire autre chose à +11
compositeur réalisateur les arrangements
t il j'ai commencé à avoir comme on dit
en anglais de big picture plutôt que
vraiment être être concentrés sur la
guitare sur mon instrument vraiment
élargir mes horizons pic fait que ces
sociétés ont finalement une bénédiction
c'est que le rock avec lesquels j'ai
deviennent des îles deviennent du coup
les l'arrivée du l'arrivée du numérique
dans dans cette industrie la salle a
marqué un énorme changement tutu le vu
qu'il a vécu j'écoutais j'écoute un peu
de tout lecteur le commentaire que de
gaulle avait fait 6 6 1
en quoi est ce que il parle de l'arrivée
des du numérique qui dira qu'il y avait
beaucoup de monde à l'époque qui suit à
l'est le numérique est encore
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils disent que tout
le monde peut peut faire n'importe quoi
maintenant puisqu'il disait c'est pas
parce que y'a nouvelles technologies que
plus de gens qui ont quelque chose à
dire exactement dit ce justement en tant
qu prod ou sur pie réalisateur trouver
quelqu un quelque chose à dire
ça doit être trop tête un challenge
commun en attendant ma position je sais
plus une histoire de me faire offrir des
projets de dire oui ou non
j'ai jamais encore été dans la situation
où c'est moi qui parle qui cherche
trouve et à leurs besoins
puis je me dit autant qu'un moment donné
ça va venir tian un échauffement faire
ça ouais c'est ça est-ce que je devrais
je devrai probablement faire mais il ya
un moment donné où il faut choisir ses
batailles
pis moi je me concentre sur la musique
puis j'ai eu beaucoup d'opportunités de
sortir de ce rôle mais je le sais
pertinemment qu à partir du moment où je
décide de faire plus jean fermant une
musique si je me mets à penser quatre
ans par jour sur youtube à chercher les
prochaines justin bieber je veux faire
quatre heures par jour de moins de
musique ça c'est on était aux prises
avec cette limitation de temps là puis
je le sais que je pense à côté d'eux des
affaires des fois parce que jean j'en
entends des artistes qui sont
incroyables pipi que je me dis comment
ça se fait que j'ai passé j'ai pas eu
cette espèce de deux heures pour
rejoindre les objets pas eu l'oeil c'est
juste que j'ai pas pris le temps de
m'exposer aux nouveaux talents
puis je fais que ça finit souvent que
regrettablement je fais de la musique
puis pendant que j'étais en train de
faire un disque il ya plein de monde qui
me demandent ils font des demandes pour
enfin pour faire de la musique avec eux
ou avec des combats les autres par le
temps que je finis un projet j'ai déjà
quatre cinq projets qui ont été
proposées puis finit par prendre celui
qui est le plus intéressant
puis jusqu'à date j'en ai pas souffert
parce que j'ai jamais faite de projets
qui m'ont qui m'ont laissé un goût amer
dans la bouche ou qui que j'ai regretté
avoir fait dans l'exemple puis je fais
très peu d'albums qui quand il considère
que j'ai travaillé sept jours sur sept
pendant vingt ans j'ai fait très peu
d'albums parce que aussi la façon dont
moi je travaille et il ya des
réalisateurs qui kikai leur travail
commence les chansons sont déjà écrites
menthe ou t'es déjà fait fait une
question de talent en studio avec les
avec les artistes d'enregistrer l'album
fait théorique robben il peut faire
quatre albums en même temps sans carbone
six albums en même temps pendant le même
été il met des équipes en place dans
différents studios puis se promène d'un
sujet à l'autre qu'ils écoutent pizy ans
assez bon mais bossut moi je pense que
le dernier emprunt devrait être doublé
il fait ses recommandations pendant une
heure ou deux presse hi hi saxon cas
dans notre studio pif à la même affaire
moi j'écris jusqu'au écrit toutes les
chansons dans le processus créatif
depuis le début c'est ce jour là je
viens de terminer un album de ludovic
bour joueur est venu me trouve en
californie au mois de mars au mois
d'avril
on a passé un mois ensemble ces jours
sur sept à écrire des chansons pour son
nouvel album
après ça aussitôt que tu revenir en
ville on a commencé à enregistrer puis
on a peut-être lui avait tourné cet été
j'ai l'accompagnant tourner enfin quitte
à risques puis à toutes les moments où
il y en avait pas de show on est en
studio à travailler l'album en écrire
une coupe de trône de plus mais je veux
dire j'écris je le drôme la baise les
claviers les guitares puis le jeu fait
l'enregistrement j'enregistre les
voitures l'éditing chez le mixage avec
cette application a assez lourde quand
même qui demande beaucoup de temps et
beaucoup d'énergie avec je fais pas
beaucoup de projets en quantité mais je
dis c'est pour chaque ou fois que je dis
oui je dis non peut-être 25 30 fois
tient ailleurs
puis j'ai essayé à un moment donné j'ai
engagé un assistant puis je me suis dit
je vais pouvoir dire oui à plus de
projet puis ça petit vraiment concluants
parce que je me rends compte que la
façon dont j'ai bâti ma réputation c'est
que les gens viennent me voir parce qu'
ils veulent ils pensent pas parce que ça
va être meilleur que s'ils vont voir
quelqu'un dos mais part ça va sonner
demain ça va être
ils vont voir cette vibe l'ofppt cette
espèce d'expérience studio là avec moi
c'était que je commence à déléguer les
artistes et leur travail se sentent un
peu délaissé
je parle je pense un électeur avec
maxime british l'époque je pense travail
sur son 4e but son cinquième album puis
je vais engager un assistant qui doit
vraiment bon puis qui était en
particulier était très bon avec les
violons les arrangements de violon j'ai
fait un arrangement de violence était
magistral c'était savais pas dans leur
motion j'ai la larme à l'oeil je
capotais puis un peu jaloux parce que je
me disais je serai jamais capable faire
un arrangement de violon de même depuis
deux jours tant marc arrive juifs
entendre la tonne pensant qu'ils vont
chier à terre midi mais sans les
violences à gaza
c'est pis c'est pas parce que violente
est pas bon et c'est parce que marthe
marc n'importe quel artiste qui
m'engagent m'engage parce qu'ils ont
entendu ce que je fais puisqu'il sort
deux mois puis c'est ce qu'il leur plaît
ouais efficiente en quelque chose
d'autre même si moi je trouve sa
meilleure ça veut dire que l artiste
votre sa mère parce que c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé qui a acheté way fait que
free le hockey est ce que tu sens que ce
qu'est ce que ces accords est ce que sam
assouvie donc ton désir créatifs à 100%
parce que ça veut dire travailler avec
les artistes droit et parce que mettons
en parlant de du dis que tu veux faire
la musique le plus possible - talent
d'avoir un désir de créer quelque chose
avec l'artiste est ce que tu sens que
met-on justement dans cet exemple ou est
ce que tu dis est ce comme si c'est
vraiment ça c'est vraiment malade puis
que si la décision de revenait à toi ça
reste très sûr mais parce que l'artiste
a une idée de qu'est ce que tu fais ça
limite un petit peu tes possibilités
d'un point de vue technique oui ça
limite les possibilités mais moi je
pense que les limitations sont la chaux
une limite c'est la sphère la plus
importante le processus créatif rhin
pierre musique c'est encore plus vrai
maintenant alors qu'on a dans ton iphone
tu peux enregistrer un nombre illimité
de piste dans garageband pas tout les
sens pour d'autres on peut faire un
album datant iphone dernièrement je
faisais le la démonstration de mes amis
je sais garage band dans l'iphone 104 99
c'est gratuit il est repensé qui vient
en tout cas c'est soit gratuit soit ça
coûte 5 pièces moi j'ai un iphone un
institut iphone 6 aces de velours 5 6
ans puis il ya plus de puissance
musicale là dedans que mon studio au
complet quand j'ai fait deux premiers
albums d'andrée waters qui a vendu 120
mille copies puis je sais pas combien de
numéros 1 x sa mamie samad imagine entre
l'iphone et calais beat enregistré 60
avec un thème qu'il fallait coupes avec
la lazio qu'elle était effective
je pense que on a trop d'outils on a
trop d'options on a trop de plugins
on a trop de compresseurs roddick il
trop de son piano 20 son piano te tue
vraiment besoin de tout cela alors que
dans le meilleur suivi au monde ya
peut-être un piano droit puis un piano
occupe dates ci-dessous
je pense que les limitations sont
vraiment importants puits - je cite des
raisons que je fais pas d'album sur
l'autre tout le monde poursuit tant la
question c'est surtout les compagnies 10
passes les compagnes disent qu ils
entendent tout le temps mes maquettes
ouais si tu fais un album de marie mai
ou un album de marc dupré ou un album de
vie pour jouable j'écris des tonnes
c'est moi qui ai chanté à makati qui est
affecté les communistes n'ont tremblé
contre justine en jeu moi je serais pour
quoi faire
je sais la difficulté qu'un taux plein
d'outils petit et mettez mais au profit
des autres mais terme année c'est un
petit coq et qui garantit une grande
pompe plus de tout temps joué dupont qui
peut-être le temps fait du punk puis si
je sors le toit du pont qui va faire du
pontet sauf qu'i am années quand après
avoir tous les styles à tous les
instruments pour ça c'est quand je peux
tout faire je fais que ckoi moitié
qu'est-ce que je fais là c'est très
difficile mais moi pis moi c'est une
question de personnalité ou si tu sais
moi j'ai pas légaux si j'ai pas le
besoin de validation du public puis j'ai
pas légaux que j'ai pas besoin qu'on me
regarde comme woippy comme comme
écrivain mais il faut par jour quel
point je suis beauté même si je suis
vraiment très bien fait que c'est une
question de personnalité moi je me
jetais je suis à mon meilleur quand
j'aide quelqu'un d'autre à s'exprimer
c'est niaiseux mais j'ai un moment donné
je marchais je marquais pas j'étais vous
je prends j'étais à key west en floride
puis vint vieux monsieur jean aveugle
indien il était debout pire comme une
table pichot pas ce qu'ils faisaient
était sa rue principale puis je commence
à lire et des découpures de journaux sur
un board
puis finalement c'est un genre de médium
hindous reconnue internationalement
puis il y avait ce genre barack obama le
consultait genre une fois par mois sur
des décisions du vip quelqu'un il y
avait des photos de lui toutes les
leaders mondiaux je sais que ce qui fait
cette sacrée festin vraiment j'étais
juste en train de lire les semaines par
les pays me dit vous mangez normes et
les yeux fermés déjà loge de sa rage
dans jeune homme dit mon impression il
dit vous êtes une trampoline trampoline
qu'est ce qui dit il il y vous jeudi à
washington polynésie oui il dit vous
êtes venus ici pour aider les autres à
sauter plus haut fait là je dis ok je
pense à mon métier puis trouve ça quand
même drôle devrait manquer tout ce que
je fais dans la vie c'est aider les
autres à faire des listes c'est fou pis
là je dis ok mais moi si je veux sauter
plus haut si je t'ai caredda aider les
autres à sauter plus haut puis moi je me
sentais plus haut dit vous dans une
autre vie vous avez sauté très haut
c'est pas votre tour à tour est passé
maintenant vous aider les autres facs tj
pas quelqu'un qui s'y spirituel que ce
répit mais c'était quand même une belle
image prix même si ça sortait de nulle
part puisque c'est juste une coïncidence
sally illustrait bien ma personnalité je
fais pas comme avant le spotlight le
site opposa castor pas parce qu'il ya un
petit quelque chose qui voudraient
sauter plus haut nous non non c'est
juste pour le mettra au défi
mais non c'est vraiment me sens bien je
viens de finir un album puis je m'en
rends californie puis j'ai passé
différents supports de l'opus one bud la
pression de la californie fait la télé
du studio pts se construit pour
travailler quand même te mène son laptop
ça continue c'est surtout que je suis
beaucoup de mixbeat mastering gay fait
que je veux pas dire non à ces contrôles
là parce que c'est comme le seul travail
que j'ai que je peux faire à distance si
un jour je décide de me re localiser
deux façons
permanente ailleurs qu'au québec je vais
pouvoir continuer à faire ça sans être
présent physiquement c'est alors
quelqu'un tu écris des chansons
réalistes des dix faut que ce soit
l'autre disponible physiquement pour
travailler avec l'artiste way fait que
je continue à dire oui à des contrôles
de mix de mastering des fois de la
musique de télé du scoring suite mais
sinon je travaille le couple de jours
par semaine maximum a dit t il
maintenant avec la proche tamment du
numérique mais de plus en plus de
réalisateurs ou maintenant on a vécu de
boxe tout est dans ton apthorp date site
de l'île sont là dedans tout et des
drames là dedans se fait à tout âge est
pratiquement je sais qu'un laptop pitot
l approche plus haute cour de nos folles
en studio ça prend des prêts emballante
ça prend du vieux gay vintage apprend
les amplis s'apprend pis les deux
approches des femmes tout sous la dent
que j'avais été un peu un genre de
débris de la bête en hybride mais je
penche plutôt du côté si ça sonne bien
c'est bon c'est un processus un pacte
ali il m'intéresse pas vraie paix sur
terre pour le trip de débit non non non
non c'est sûr que non pitié j'ai fait
des tests a/b à l'aveuglent opi l'etape
le versus les simulations je vous écoute
à 6 mois puis mes trois amis geeks avec
le plus d'oreilles que j'ai rencontré
dans ma vie sont pas capables avec le
meilleur système de soins sont pas
capables d'entendre la différence
imagine le public c'est moi je ne veux
pas bocce parce que je me dis quel
public entend faire la différence mais
je viens quand même du côté musical et
non pas du côté un génie il ya beaucoup
de gens qui travaillent en studio qui
tripent sur l'équipement petit trip sur
les micros qui tripent sur les vies les
vieilles machines
moi je trouve sa musique tu les outils
qui me permettent de transmettre ma
vision musicale puis ce que j'entends
dans ma tête de la façon la moins
obstrue ziv la plus pratique la plus
facile c'est sûr que je vois utiliser
tiens je me rappelle parce que moi j'ai
vécu toute la transition quand j'ai
commencé à faire de la musique ça
existait pas un simulateur
ampli guitare puis ça n'existait pas
info sons de piano qui sonne vraiment
comme un vrai son de piano be ainsi de
suite
puis fait que j'avais vraiment un multi
pistes à bobine les consoles qui met à
mesure que les outils sont devenues
disponibles dans l'ordinateur gelé
testait licka j'ai découvert un
compresseur qui sonnait aussi bien sinon
mieux que le compresseur que j'utilisais
externe
j'ai switché puis de nos jours vraiment
là j'ai aucun problème avec les gens qui
tripent sur les vieux studio le vieil
équipement parce que c'est un trip comme
un autre lot et les mots moi ça
m'importe peu
pour vrai c'est si je capable de faire
le son du ka pas d'en acheter un album
complet dans mon téléphone je fais c'est
la tonne c'est une bonne toune
enregistré tout croche dans un téléphone
c'est bien plus fun écouter clinton de
marde enregistré dans un studio à quatre
millions avec des lic avec le même
équipement qui survient après les
beatles on sent foule
le succès des beatles vient pas du vieil
équipement à l'époque les beatles y
avait eu accès à tous les outils qu'on a
accès en ce moment et aurait utilisé y
était tellement visionnaire le à toutes
les fois qu'ils avaient quelque chose de
nouveau qui sortait il incluait dans
l'eure dans la world flo fait je pense
vraiment pas que les gens qui disent en
moi j'utilise ça parce que les beatles
utiliser ce un argument valide
c'est vraiment un truc jimi hendrix là à
toutes les focales nouvelle [ __ ] qui
sortent elles il y en avait il y en
existe et 4 le cahier morne des pédales
c'est une [ __ ] de fausses une [ __ ]
dow a toutefois qu'il ait quelque chose
de nouveau il ya l'eau guitar center à
hollywood il l'acheter puis il l'inclure
dans son nouvel album ci existait
aujourd'hui là il serait le premier à
voir une guitare cybernétique branché
dans huit ans relie digitaux qui font
des sons qu'on n'a jamais entendu de
notre vie alors que des fans de jimi
hendrix qui s'estime sur qui elle [ __ ]
de force de 1969 faut que j'achète pic
elle manque des batteries fenêtre de
temps pour sont exactement comme jimi
hendrix est le dernier qui sonnerait
comme jimi hendrix en 2010 jimmy hendrix
c'est mal fait passer à deux temps
c'est moi la musique c'est dans vie le
tipi à l'université team et ont atterri
dans jazz classique comme charlie parker
s'est blessé comme acquis dans le temps
des années 40 aux autres avait quelque
chose de nouveau plein d'autres faux
faux faux imiter ceux à la perfection
mais ségolène td td rebelles d'accueil à
qui la musique pop swing ce que vous
faites le avec vos grands orchestres
leur phoque date outre dans des petits
clubs puis genre on joue plus de notre
possible pige à c'était pas des
traditionalistes vraiment pas dit
aujourd'hui c'est des traditionalistes
qui essaie de les imiter en 35 les
honorer et xsara l'or qui ne les
honorent aucunement un au confrère 6e
puis c'est pour ça qu'ils mettront moins
urbaines comme vérité ol je me dise
exactement c'est comme les beatles des
années 2000 tu par ses clients ayant des
bonnes thoune qui utilisent les outils
modernes halles qui sont à leur
disposition pour créer des nouveaux sont
que légèrement tendus avant voilà puis
c'est exactement la même
la même démarche nalement absolument je
suis tellement d'accord avec moi je me
situe vraiment le temps de mon téléphone
un micro qui se branche directement puis
une guitare fiche correct tout un
approche de simplicité volontaire je
pense en général à vie ou dans ta vie
mais finalement c'est ce que ça se
transmet la musique ou 6 et puis je
t'écoute et à un segment avec mick swing
attention oui oui qui il était monté de
10 watts et à une certaine époque j'ai
déjà échappés puis j'avais 60 guitare le
jeu réduit à 15 et guitare et quelle
guitare ça c'est le plus implicite est
possible mais c'est assez simple par
evans pense à ça parce que ça comprend
les bases politiques en acoustique
déjà la tse puis aussi il faut compter
que des fois je tends tournée ou un fait
que j'ai j'ai un certain nombre
d'instruments qui va suivre la tournée
dans le troc com en appel pédales et les
entrepôts thé avec laquelle je peux pas
toujours revenir après chaque show puis
entre les choses tournent au québec
c'est pas comme aux états unis la bande
à part en tournée à part de chez eux
pendant quatre mois à venir
cette fois autant pas en tournée on va
faire deux champions
ça avec moi même quand je tournais je
tends studio fait le lundi mardi
mercredi jeudi jetant studio puis après
ça je m'en vais à la fin de semaine
faire une coupe de cheveux fait souvent
des instrumentistes utilise une strate
telecaster pu ne laisse pas au pire deux
guitares acoustiques mais là il y en a
déjà cinq qui sont sa tournée piste a
besoin d'une strate tu ne laisses pas en
studio tu as besoin d'avoir une deuxième
sans compter des backups effects et a
besoin de sang chaud cinq tranches
hautes a besoin dans leur change pour
chaque t'as déjà cinq six sept guitare
qui sent qu'ils sont plus dans son
studio recta besoin de des doublons le
haut mais si les stocks non mais en même
temps ce parce que oui j'ai réduit mais
c'est vrai jal échappés sous un titre ça
n'a pas de bon sens quand je me suis
séparé j'ai vidé le garage j'ai trouvé
d'éditeur que je fais très moyen avec le
rival mais il y avait le dvi de menthol
igor pardon c'est le guitariste depeche
mode lui qu'un qui lui compose layton le
pic inquiet qu'un qui ils sont en
processus de composition dans le fond
lui écrit une maquette tranquillement
quelqu'un de maquettes il a présenté aux
autres groupes le fu narbonne puis lui
dans le fond il porte d'un instrument
fait que genre il se promène y voient un
instrument qui aime une guitare mettons
en forme d'étoilé différents 1,62 me
plaît pas sa maquette à patrice je
serais curieux de voir mettons le le
garage ou un genre de personne ceci dit
que dans la v60 le il doit en avoir mais
tout le monde a son processus mais c'est
vrai qu'un nouvel instrument peut
inspirer de nouvelles idées ouais fait
que j'ai quand même une rotation
il ya des instruments que c'est avec
lesquels j'ai vraiment beaucoup joué
j'ai enregistré beaucoup de chansons
avec qui tu as envie de continuer à
évoluer puis avoir un son qui qui change
un peu avec les ânes évidemment fait que
ça m'arrive de dire bon baisser la tête
alors je laisse quiz est autant que je
pouvais la squeezer sont bons services
et et attire comme les
les joueurs d'arqués qui lève les
numéros de gillet au plafond non en faut
que ça continue à servir l'église et à
partir du moment où quelque chose peut
être un instrument est épuisée à mes
yeux il peut être super inspirant pour
quelqu'un mais oui j'ai jamais joué
tissu fait que je me sente requis jjp
longue passe au suivant
des fois je j'en ai données en masse sur
les 60 j'en ai donné à des petits
cousins qui commença à jouer puis ou des
petits cousins qui était vraiment rendu
bon petit méritait une meilleure guitare
que la guitare de mardi qui avait fait
que je dis c'est un jour de chance
d'avoir une assise de rap avec j'essaie
de donner au suivant un peu aussi la c1
là dessus j'en ai donné une coupe à des
à des enchères de charité une préféré
que ça n'irait jamais
je pense que non non j'aime j'aime pas
l'idée de dépendre d'un outil
irremplaçable
je me sens à savoir que je cite en
allemagne sur une session je peux aller
louer une strate pile pharma job avec
cette porte une strate une fender
stratocaster général réussit pas reconnu
photo des musiciens qui est content dit
vraiment profond dans les tic
mais c'est sam au pij passé mais mon
côté minimaliste
j'aime pas ça m'a dit je l'utilisais sur
tout les albums que j'ai fait dans ma
vie je pourrais pas m'en passer
je peux m'en passer j'aime savoir que je
peux partir six mois californie puis
simon triplex passe au feu ma vie
continue dit je vais pas pleurer un
instrument ou même un objet c'est fait
que mes photos importantes sont
survenues à 8 6 puis sinon mais le monde
que j'aime son envie sans quand les
choses et on côté minimaliste dans les
hautes sphères de ta vie ça se manifeste
comme en chine et a pas de doute
ben sassi manifeste c'est une bonne
question parce rendu tellement naturel
mois puis j'essaie de ne pas faire la
morale à personne je ne savais pas
influencer personnes de façon explicite
disent les gens qui m'entourent y trouve
qu'il ya ma façon de vivre votre la leur
qu'ils veulent et mulets certaine dans
les habitudes c'est cool mais sinon je
vais pas faire sentir quelqu'un coupable
parce qu'il s'agit d'une septième paire
de chaussures
dis moi je trouve que trois sets assez
fait que j'y pense pas vraiment accès à
mon minimaliste mais c'est sûr que les
gens m'en parlent
je pense que c'est pas mal un peu dans
de toutes les façons c'est autant la
quantité d'ingrédients que je garde chez
nous pour cuisiner que la quantité de
chaussures que j'ai
les instruments de musique ça s'est fait
tout naturellement malgré toi plutôt
qu'un choix conscient de dire qui le vit
une vie de simplicité maintenant à
vienne famille vraiment pas fait et déjà
la cg je me sens du contre rapide mc
avoir plus de stock c'est parce que je
vienne famille pauvre mais que tout le
monde samedi
tout le monde sait vraiment j'ai eu
beaucoup de support de mes parents puis
fait que je viens d'une famille pauvre
mais unis j'ai pas grandi en associant
confort et richesses avec bonheur que
c'est je m'en suis pas rendu compte à
l'époque mais je me rends compte
aujourd'hui que ça a beaucoup influencé
mais après ce que j tard à montréal puis
j'ai commencé à travailler puis avoir un
peu plus les moyens
ses 15 juges de l'échappée avec les
guitares ce site est hanté loin du
minimaliste me dis-je
je me rappelles tu sais quand je voyais
un vieux vidéoclip de bon jovi puis je
voyais sambora creamer un cheval entre
meurt quand j'étais jeune j'allais suri
baby justin kremer alors qu'on s'en
câlisse d'avril échapper un peu sur les
guitares sur les instruments musée pitt
c'est bon on avait une maison sa rive
sud qui était trop grande pour nos
besoins impies qui coûtait trop cher à
entretenir par conséquent il est très
rapide
la souffleuse c'est toute la patente
kate a vraiment pas besoin mais que pour
une raison ou pour une autre
parce que tu as large et samba pis en
je suis parti avec mon ex qui en a fait
le tour des états unis dans une roulotte
airstream de 16 pieds non puis lost est
clair qu'elle la on peut pas mener grand
chose ne fait jamais une guitare pis mon
t-shirt préféré mais de t-shirts préféré
c63 parts de bofi deux paires de bob
bell pizza parce qu'elle le storage est
assez limité la dalle les ramenant
puisse poteau que le plus cher c'est pas
de ta faute tu laisses le diable en fait
on a fait ça fait qu'on ait réduit par
nécessité juste pour le broyeur
mais c'est quand je suis revenu dans ma
maison de 2000 pieds carrés avec que je
me suis rendu compte à quel point ça
n'avait pas de bon sens on vient de
passer six mois super heureux je vous en
avais tout ce dont on avait besoin d'un
pilote et d'un côté je me suis rendu
compte qu'on avait 3 tv dans une maison
pour deux personnes dix sacres à main
pour vrai que c'est sorti puis je me
suis mis à lire sur le minimalisme puis
sur la simplicité bien jour
l'indépendance financière pitt et je me
suis rendu compte que je sous-estimaient
tous que ça coûtait de maintenir quelque
chose sans même acheter quoi que ce soit
de neuf là les nos possessions continue
à coûter de l'argent en vrai qu'on les
ait acheté parce que ce soit en frais
d'assurance c'est leur site à 60 guitare
vous assure je continue à payer pour
posséder ce qui les attendait à sûr mais
faut que tu aies une place les mains
avec là on avait une plus grosse maison
juste pour accommoder nos biens inutiles
fait la bibliothèque d'achat et potec
notre pays n'hypothèque pour une plus
grosse maison d'aidé de l'entretien pour
une plus grosse maison qui se paie de
l'assurance pour une plus grosse maison
que des taxes municipales de taxco la
fecq les 72 heures ils sont reflétés
dans les coups continuent de toutes ces
affaires lors il peut-être les
assurances les techniciens pas de da ce
cas là on se rend pas compte du fait que
ces cages me suis rendu compte de temps
après avoir passé six mois dans 86
picard et petit noeud coulant retomber
dans 2000 je faisais ça pas de ce type
bon ça c'est là que j'ai commencé à
vraiment faire à des changements dans ma
vie important si c'est plus vite et plus
flexible le titre peut plus décider du
jour au lendemain
et finalement la double que je fais je
tenais pas malade décidait ou twitter
burnout je vous fous tu prennes un break
mais là les dépenses continuent tandis
que quand tu diminues ce tu étais très
flexible d'environ 1 200 dirais que j'ai
envie de faire se gausser moi je peux le
faire mais ça se traduit notamment dans
la capacité d'accepter des contres moins
payant ouais mais kate a vraiment envie
de faire ce que j'ai découvert c'est que
les contrats moins payant que tu as
vraiment envie de faire des femmes yeux
finalement c'est dans l'esprit d'un
album finalement il est meilleur il va
en plus il joue plus à radio puis finit
par être tout autant sinon plus payant
que le contrôle qu'ils étaient plus
payant la base que tu avais pas envie de
faire que tu aurais fait du jeu reposera
bosch parce que tu es professionnel tu
fais comme du monde non mais tu peux pas
fait qu'est la passion n'ont fait que je
pense que même en prenant des contrats
moins payant puis en faisant des choix
qui sont pas basés sur le revenu ça
finit par avoir des répercussions
positives sur des finances ça c'était
comme un espèce de 25.5 tome est un
effet secondaire
dommage collatéral un effet secondaire
que j'avais papa tout anticipé tant qu
en travaillant moins sur des affaires
que j'ai plus envie de faire ça allait
finir par être encore plus payant
qu'avant je ne pensais pas que ça allait
faire se faisait avec même pas ça -
chaque saison c'est fou moi ça
m'intéresse tellement tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est minimaliste mais j'ai
toujours toujours tenu loin de la
surconsommation j'ai toujours eu mais
ton
j'ai un attachement au matériel mais de
matériel de qualité permettant de
racheter une fois une affaire ça va
coûter cher mais avant tout à fait
pendant longtemps puis puis seulement
justement j'avais mes parents sont
séparés mais j'ai vidé la maison
familiale puis c'est un cauchemar
le nombre d'affaires accumulé qui n'ont
jamais servi ou qui ont servi une fois
outil mais tout ça parce que tu dis
c'est ceci juste d'accumuler du rien
prendre la place consommé depuis dans
tout seule espèce de la décroissance
qu'on parle de plus en plus de dire
exactement ce que tu me dois de dire on
va travailler moins mais de façon plus
ce qu'elle tati flotte des fois ça va se
refléter comme tulle expliquant quelque
chose qui va être plus passionnant
surtout un domaine des ordres de même si
c'est pas le coup même si c'est parce
que c'est cela qu'on l'ait bénéfices
soit examen exact on produit sur un
podcast de gâvres et l'inde ou du bois
puis le dernier podcast fait c'était son
rêve et si on travaillait - puis
dernièrement prenez l'exemple de
microsoft qui avait qui avaient laissé
leur leurs employés travaillent et
quatre jours par semaine en place de 5
ok qu'apparemment que ça va eu des
répercussions vraiment positive sur tout
le rendement de tous les employés ça me
surprend pas en colombie britannique
mon frère habite sur une île en
colombie-britannique qui s'appelle sorte
spring l'équipe d'yvon l'école quatre
jours par semaine
ah ouais je vous hais après cela ils
sont aussi qualifiés sinon plus pour
aller au à l'université là bah oui je
sais une journée complète de moins par
semaine c'est 20% de moins de scolarité
pour un résultat égal ou supérieur
le seul 20% là de ton temps qui peut le
mettre dans le million d'ha fort
exactement puis mes neveux sont
incroyables je ne veux qu'ils me
virtuose de l'harmonica juste parce
qu'il ya le temps de développer autre
chose
puis j'ai un autre neveu qui qui tripent
sur la robotique puisqu'ils cole c'est
que cette école là la journée où il n'ya
pas de d'école l'école est quand même
verte
pis il ya plein de cours parascolaires
qui sont offerts fait que 6 s'attendent
de venir à l'école la cinquième jour
puis faire la robotique faire de la
soudure faire de la peinture faire
n'importe quoi d'autre
tu peux faut que les jeunes se trouvent
une passion
puis il la développe dans cette
cinquième journée lopy saygnasone mais
ça lisent ça les outils pour décider
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire dans vite
ils peuvent essayer plein d'affaires
d'une année à l'opie finalement tombé
sur une passion qui est soupçonné tout
ça ça m'intéresse vraiment beaucoup
puis
on change de sujet complètement métier
on compare les deux pas de revenus type
touche chic de une période au début
comme comme sous-commission plus
difficile aujourd'hui c'est s'il y en a
un qui et pour qui hop parce que ça va
bien pour tout en mettant le fait que
trouver aussi est ce qu'en fait ma
question est ce que je porte en plus
méchamment est ce qu est ce que ça c'est
venu tout seul en guillemets le fait est
un passionné de mettre ton tu as ton
énergie là dedans puis ton talent puis
l'argent est venu comme par défaut ou il
vrai que tu demandes à qui comment je
peux faire pour que vive la mort puis
c'est quoi les moines y est qu'il faut
que je prenne pour y arriver je pense je
peux pas vraiment prendre beaucoup de
crédit pourra pour avoir planifié quoi
que ce soit de positif dans mes finances
parce que non mais non mais c'est vrai
maintenant je peux prendre un crédit par
mes devoirs les quelques dernières
années pour pouvoir optimiser l'argent
que finalement j'ai fait dans le passé
mais on est mal le côté économies mais
pas dépenser trop ça provient vraiment
juste du fait que j'ai grandi sans
dépenser quoi c'était seulement mon mode
d'opération c'est puis je pense que j'ai
fait plus d'argent que les autres
réalisateurs québécois qui ont fait des
heat inc je pense que la différence est
que j'ai moins de penser que la plupart
qui sont partis en par des instruments
dans le grand studio pour les kits puis
que j'ai travaillé tellement c'est que
j'ai une grosse période de 15 ans je
remets pas eu le temps
même si j'avais voulu dépenser jeux
repas du temps parce que j'ai des six
jours sur sept en studio tu es quand je
me suis séparé en 2016
je me suis retrouvé avec zéro envie de
faire de music for ever finalement ça a
changé avec le temps mais je parle mon
état d'esprit quand je suis séparé c'est
comme
ford focus jeune et assez fait j'ai eu
une bonne ronde ouais merci bonsoir je
déménage dans l'ouest dans une roulotte
dans le désert c'était vraiment ça ouais
je les fait c'était fini sur quelle
heure en faisant des armes août après
depuis je tends secondaire 2 que je
pratique ma guitare dix ans par jour
puis que quand j'ai arrêté de
pratiquement 10 buts en dix heures par
jour c'est parce que j'ai commencé à
écrire des toons dix heures par jour 1
pi le fait que ça commence à 13 ans 14
ans puis là je te ranges à 40 2 puis
tout d'un coup je suis dans le désert
puis ma vie je suis retraité tout ce
qu'il termine et c'est comme ça va pas
dans leur fait là je me tourne les
pouces puis je me suis dit j'ai sur ma
bucket list quelques items que je
voulais faire le premier hiver après ma
séparation quand je te rendu dans
l'ouest puis une de ces affaires là
c'était apprendre comment optimiser mes
investissements
parce que je savais que j'avais mis
beaucoup d'argent de côté
après 15-20 ans de travail est vraiment
vraiment fort et l'argent quand même
j'ai fait plein d'émissions de télé puis
ça donne quand même beaucoup de droits
d'auteur puis mais j'avais pas trop
comment ça marche et l'investissement
j'avais dit reér investi par la madame
de la banque loris club faisait pas
grand chose toute la patente que
j'achète une pile de livres le mystère
ridicule là j'avais plus de livres dans
ma roulotte que quoi que ce soit d'autre
j'ai passé des semaines et des semaines
et des semaines à lire ça fait que a
précisé qu'à partir du moment où j'ai
ggg abri à un optimiser mes
investissements pour qu'ils puissent me
faire vivre c'est pour le futur j'ai
comme me suis mis à souffler un peu plus
speed effects aouiti dans les dernières
années j'ai vraiment appris comment ça
fonctionnait mais sinon je peux pas
vraiment dire ah j'étais vraiment
intelligent avec mon argent piqué c'est
juste que parent sécurité puis par
manque de talent je les dépenses et je
n'ai pas dépensé alors passer mon temps
à travailler puis à créer des nouvelles
chansons des nouvelles musiques de telle
éthique qui continua à faire que
l'argent leur entretien
mais juste l'idée de faire d'écrire des
chansons défendre avec de télé - béton
depuis 18 ans est 8 heures je garde ma
vie comme le sien avant des geeks des
geeks des guides des 200 déjà fait un
peu moins de dix lacs et métiers il ya
des années que ça pis c'est cool c'est
le fun jeux de la musique trip tu
travailles tu es fatigué en fin d'année
tu dis bon tu regardes ce jeu capable de
payer mes affaires ça va je peux même
avec un peu de côté mais chris
l'impression d'avoir travaillé comme un
fou puis-je comparable aux autres d'y
remédier je prétends l'argent je fais
pas autant d'argent
j'ai vraiment prêter l'argent se dit la
performance
amman il ya une limite il ya un plafond
t il à la faune à moins de 10 mètres à
charge et d'autres qui vont le faire
pour moins cher enfin pour moins cher
exactement fac tu finis qui est
justement ce site fait quarante mille
l'a condamné à faire juste là giggs de
couture mais souvent c'est parce que
c'est bien souvent c'est vraiment pas ce
fac
l'idée d'écrire des tonnes pour la tv
décret détonne par sa radio qui joue qui
joue c'est la douce at elle est aussi
parce qu'on s'entend que beaucoup de
guarin de l'heure en ce moment
le téléthon c'est l'échec tôt cet
automne après si tu dors pillé l'argent
construire notre équipe i de n'importe
quel homme d'affaires qui doit parler il
le trouve tout demandeur de droit de
l'argent quand dans l'histoire ce que
ces premiers trucs qu'ils aient donné
absolument cette semaine d'un glossy et
énergie les prix à sa bonne place j'ai
pas eu ce mandat là parce que parce que
je viens pas d'une famille qui sait
comment faire d'argent c'est tout de
travail des gens qui travaillent fort
piquant car l ouvrage comme on dit mais
c'est pas des entrepreneurs en tant que
tel c'est pas des gens qui avaient des
connaissances là dessus avec moi j'étais
un peu dans le néant
c'est une surprise pour moi de constater
que m
waouh je me rappelle la première fois
que j'ai eu un chèque de droits d'auteur
significatif c'était pour l'émission
ramdam ouais
puis encore aujourd'hui tout le monde
connaît pour les tours de marteau puis
marie may be un site mais je sais rien
sorti pour l aide de l'agencé
non mais la dame elle-même j'ai fait
plus d'argent avec des émissions que je
vois que nos mecs est jamais entendu
parler ouais que avec marie-mai endroits
d'autant mon mari mais c'est sûr que tu
es payé pour réaliser l'album il yad
autres affamés qui on parle de propriété
intellectuelle puis d'écrire des
chansons pop que tout le monde connaît
lé jeudi
j'ai fait plus d'argent à faire des
musiques de telit personne connaît que
j'ai fait à faire des chansons qui joue
à radio 1 million de fois que tout le
monde connaît c'est juste que la façon
dont c'est la structure est faite noir
c'est pas payant ford et une pop tu sais
juste pas payant faire des thunes pop
six au québec c'est ça qui est ça puisse
faire de la musique pour la télé ça
l'est plus qu'à chaque fois deux jours
en faut de l'émission passe loin tout
soit une coupe de berlin sous payent
plus que c'est une tonne qui pensent à
radio fait mouche n'était pas au courant
de tout partout moi j'y travaille à
radio puis pas sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde sur ducourtioux
ben il ya beaucoup de manques sont au
courant de ça j'ai déjà qu'ils me
demandent des conseils là des nouveaux
lots qui ont eu une tonne sur un album
qui a joué six fois radio qui
connaissent déjà 40 fois plus que moi le
droit d'auteur moi je suis je suis
tellement il n'y a rien
nick et face à tout ça je crois surpris
parce que tu me dises ça va loin mais je
comprends mais c'est vrai que je suis
vraiment nul pour plusieurs raisons
premièrement c'est pas ma force tout ça
deuxièmement quand j'ai constaté que
c'était vraiment plus payant faire de la
musique insignifiante pour une émission
télé cash insignifiante serait possible
de musique est pas bonne je peux dire
que l'émission telepo bonne ça veut dire
que la musique alors pas une grosse
importance
je sais en 2,5 g dames look manolo et
découragé parties s'accordent équipes
r&d courage et puis après c'est un autre
c'est l'importance de 7 tonnes de 7
secondes là est assez limité on s'est
dit c'est pas la star du show qui a
personne qui va fredonner de ta petite
pensée qui on parle pas juste du thème
de ramdam fait que cette musique là la
pop beaucoup d'importance en soi est
importante comme étant un des blocs qui
celui-là patente mais versus nous sommes
les mêmes qui le plus gros hit de marc
dupré que ces mots qui a écrit ça c'est
sûr que au niveau ego puis au niveau
signifie au niveau de ce que ça signifie
culturellement les austin en partie de
famille chez man verglas qui me demande
d'écrire des tonnes que c'était écrit
thibault en tant que musicien qui ai
grandi en écoutant des chansons pop qui
a été touchée par des chansons pop qui
est encore touchée je vous écoute la
radio puis vient le temps qui me touche
puis je pars à brailler je comprends la
puissance de la musique dans envie de
faire partie de ça puis tu as envie de
contribuer au bassin culturelle plutôt
envie que quand tu vas mourir tu étais
six enfants dit mon grand père avait
fait cette note se rappelle du t1
alors qu'est ce si j'avais je m'étais
concentré afin de musique nathalie
serait bien plus riche aujourd'hui fait
quand j'ai commencé à recevoir mais mais
mais mais mais droit d'auteur puis je
voyais que si j'avais trois hits
d'andrée watters tic qui m'avait
rapporté 4500 pièce pendant mon année
vite j'avais 60 et cette transition de
ramdam qui m'ont rapporté 27 mille
quatre cents
cette année là j'aurais dit fuck andrée
watters plus fort que toutes les deux
artistes pop
je veux faire de la musique pour le
téléthon pigé je me rappelle de la
croisée des chemins que j'ai vécu à ce
moment-là titre que je me suis dit que
si je fais pas ci c'est clairement ce
type et de l'écrire d'être une pop
quand tu es capable d'écrire dayton que
personne n'a jamais dit votre jamais
refusé parce que c'est la musique de
télé qui est plus ou moins importante
puisse enfin plus d'argent par faut se
rappeler qu'avant d'avoir trois tonnes
dans les water ge sera un album temps
écrit 40
oui il y en a trente i7 qui sont refuse
il se fait aux salaires à leurs
appareils de 19 euros atos s'est pas
hissé pas tarder non plus à rien à voir
avec andrée watters suis pas gros succès
en dix ans non non mais mais mais l'idée
c'est que je me suis dit ok oui
concernant musique de télévision mais je
peux pas arrêter de faire la musique pop
parce que c'est ça qui me pique qui me
donne l'impression de contribuer
musicalement puis culturellement picchi
qui me rendent fier d'avoir eu une idée
puisque du monde que je connais pavon la
fredonner un moment donné tu es fax est
un peu seul
toujours en équilibre dès qu'il est
blessé face nous c'est fascinant juste
d'un point de vue complètement externe
j'ai rien à voir avec avec le milieu de
la musique c j'aurais vraiment pensé que
qu'au québec du moins pour des tonnes
autre jeu dont nous sommes les mêmes
c'est prenant la chanson que j'ai
entendu le plus souvent de toute ma vie
comme quand c'est pas moi qui s'est
cassé peluche pas ce rapport music halle
s'est piquée sur un an soit l'année où
est-ce que c'est sorti ces blocs de
développe 3 1 c'est bien plus vieux que
moi je pense 74 non mais c'est mieux que
moi mais quand c'est sorti de je
n'entendais que nous sommes et my way à
radio c'est mon plus gros après le thème
de ramdam c'est vrai que nous sommes les
mêmes c'est comme l'exemple de la toune
pop mais gentil vraiment bien construite
avec le occupé avec tout
de l'histoire d'un papy 4 mai mais c'est
une question aussi de timing c'était le
bon artiste pour la paix la bonne tonne
pour la bonne artiste au bon moment puis
si j'en suis super fier de cette chanson
lotis mais s'il faut pas oublier qu'il
ya une différence entre une bonne
chanson puis un hit
il ya plein de chansons qui sont
incroyables mais qui sont pas
nécessairement vrai détournent pour la
radio - ouais je je je compte qu'on
parle justement un peu dessus prenons
l'exemple de nous sommes les mêmes
comment met-on comment cette toune line
et c'est quoi cette école processus delà
de l'actuelle jusqu'à temps que tombent
des radios méthode mais c'est un bon
exemple parce que cet honneur une
trajectoire peu commune
en tout cas dans mon corps s'est passé
pas un archétype qui se porte souvent
pour tous et non non non parce que tiff
d'habitude moi je commence un projet
avec un artiste je fais pas de trois
projets en même temps c'est l'excellent
album de marc dupré on s'assoit on écrit
des tonnes on enregistre l'album on sort
l'album après ça je passe à autre chose
mais nous sommes les mêmes j'avais écrit
pour marie-mai en fait je l'écris avec
marie-mai fait que j'avais j'ai composé
la musique qu'on a fait les paroles
ensemble la lame a exactement note pour
note marie michaud marmite change l'ifp
et à faire entendre être l'adage
oui absolument qu'elle continue à parler
je vois là je la sortie de tien jack
jetons téléphone oui j -jacques son
téléphone à la fois minimaliste oublie
pas d'accès téléphone de fonctionner
mais je l'écris pour l'album de
marie-mai pis on avait écrit peut-être
15 tonnes pour en choisir 12 bis vers la
fin on a fait un écoute avec la
compagnie la gérance pis tout le monde
impliqué dans le projet
fyk tout le monde fallait qu'ils me
mettent leurs thèmes préférés en obtient
au final pour que finalement en face à
ce genre de palmarès des 12 meilleurs
picon flash les trous
qui revenait le moins souvent dans
l'étude préféré puis celle là est arrivé
dans les moins préférées fait qu'on l'a
flashée de l'album je l'aimé vraiment
mais je me suis pas grever les comptes
sur fait là c'est si j'avais vraiment
mis mon pied à terre leurs amis sur
l'album mais je devait probablement être
un peu d'accord puis après ça j'ai
embarqué sur l'album de marc dupré puis
habituellement je fais pas entendre des
dj kt d'autres artistes pour essayer de
les pitchs aimé marquer ma demande et
parce que marc qui aimait vraiment
montre avec marie-mai pis si vous n'êtes
pas des enfants qui étaient trop pop
pour l'album parce que marie mais c'est
quand même plus intense puis plus voir
ces grosses guitares que mon vrai visage
peut prendre une coupe d'avoir peut-être
de quoi sur lesquels tu vas accroché au
pire un refrain qu'on réutilise raoult
qui on est tombé sur nous sommes les
mêmes
je me rappelle que marc pannier en 2
minutes puis a fait comme what
vous avez pas garder ce tome josé luis
pour lui instantanément mais marc faut
dire qu'ils ont une oreille incroyable
ici c'est qu'on est là c'est sa jeunesse
déjà fait vous coupez où ils ont rejoint
ce plaquage l'oubli
[Rires]
[Musique]
pasqua lui entendu la tonne je vous
parlais comme un animateur radio sur
l'intro puis ya dix ans face au fait
j'ai trouvé une tonalité pour lui pis il
dit est un petit peu ce lot dans la mi
temps
sauf qu'on a atteint le clame accueille
le maquettisme vers son fils je fais pas
de maquillage jamais attaqué ça au final
à la version humala mixer mag remplacer
le tramway
[Musique]
ça fait tellement longtemps tellement
de jeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un petit peu plus bas ouais la jet lag
est un peu plus élevé - toutefois
d'acoustique
mais c'est même pas ces malades qui est
ce que fait on avec mes marques a capoté
depuis tout de suite entendu faut lui
donner crédit parce que ils sont ni plus
rendu compte que nous autres casse tête
je vais déployer ça fait un buzz fait
bon fait que on l'enregistré pts que ce
que tu penses que ça aurait eu le même
succès avec marie-mai et aucune façon de
savoir on le saura jamais non mais pas
bouger mais je peux pas dire parce que
c'est qu'un cette union a été rachetée
de l'album marie même en a fait écrire
une autre puis ça a été je cours c'est
un gros et où city puis c'était mieux
pour elle
je pense que c'est faux que je fasse
confiance à marion parce qu'elle aussi
était pas certaine de stoner puis comme
marque la sortie elle aurait pu être
comme déçu finalement fox si je veux
gagner tu as quelqu'un d'autre mais ça
n'a jamais été son attitude c'est depuis
le débu t a fait mieux à marcq
c'est vrai comment un morceau de l'ange
ouais c'est pas parce que ça me fait
bien mieux que ça va faire battre tout
le monde c'est à dix à la bonne tonne
pour la bonne artiste la bonne tonne
pour le bon artiste qui a aucune façon
de savoir pour ça n'a rien de cette
équipe d'études chez vous et tentez
clinton puis bon à qui ça ferait bien
cette année
ça arrive tous non non non j'écris
rarement pour rien cache-cache plus
jeunes oui mais on serait que je me
garde pour le prochain projet j'en écris
des affaires si j'ai fait un album métal
avec un médecin blain un ou deux pit et
mais c'est vraiment rare d'habitude
c'est comme ok mais un artiste qui
n'appelle t comme dernièrement marx prix
sur un album
dans deux semaines le deux semaines ils
m'appellent je finis en avant mais je
veux qu'on fasse une tournée ensemble je
sais que tu es sur l'album de ludo mais
il tombe donc j'ai joué au hockey avec
ça c'est même pas un job parce qu'il m'a
rappelé pour cent on veut toujours faire
la musique ensemble marquent la donne
pas tout le temps lundi j'ai joué au
hockey avec le dos puis il m'a dit qu'il
tournait son clip lundi puis mardi
je ne serai pas avec lui lundi et mardi
en fin de séance en demandant à ses cols
sim au club et qui est venu bien on a
écrit mme tonnes lundi on enregistrait
mardi pisser sa tendance deux autres
peut avoir une tonne fini la séance à
parce que des gens ont fini mixé et
masterisé togo ces deux grosses journées
mais mettons fait combien d'heures
dessus permet d'en dans une tonne 20 ans
20h31 fini waouh printemps fokker
campagne asie patton il a depuis
toujours été ce bain c'est vraiment avec
le
j'ai l'habitude ben la technologie eide
s'est fait que la technologie être parce
qu'ainsi bon à l'époque il fallait que
j'enregistrais des forces guitare ça
fallait que je les ai pas en livraison
amplifie 18ème ping puis bon pleine
affaire technique tpiy mais maintenant
que titre tout ce que tu fais tu peux le
garder parce que tu es la technologie
permet d'enregistrer n'importe quoi
n'importe quand pique ça sonne bien fait
que ces deux jours c'est trois jours ci
d'un petit jeu budget trois jours
partout c'est pour un album lundi parce
que tu sais pas si des fois ça peut être
un peu plus long trouver les paroles ou
des fois tu vas faire avec un paradis
pour les paroles pis il va pas amener
les la patente du premier coup fecteau
du back and forth est enfin si tutu
budget trois jours mais c'est juste que
j'aime faire si tu dis si tu fais une
semaine par thoune l'automne en écrire
plus que ce que 12,6 tout le temps
d'expérimenter un peu plus tôt le temps
de défaut d'écrire deux trois sets de
parole pour la même chanson tu fais que
métisse quand ça va bien deux jours la
décence est capable pilatus du tout
acquis et tangage tangage du monde
s'engagent personne ben c'est en deux
jours non c'est un gage personnes en
deux jours
c'est pour ça que je dis je me budget
trois jours parce que souvent je tenais
demandons surtout un cutter dans cette
année de mon temps et je tenais de mes
idées je talent et demi son chèque
souvent je vais faire toutes les
guitares de barbie après ça je vais
engager quelqu'un d'autre je vomis août
et des affaires qui mène en oeuvre dans
mes propres tourne et que je trouve ça
sent que trop fred st-gelais
j'ai engagé quelqu'un d'autre josette
que 70 ans et fait que j'envoie la tonne
aux gars avec des trucs mutés ou un
difficile l accès au travail
non il écoute la tonne qui
il y arriver chez nous avec plein
d'idées épique j'engage smaghi mme
doiron est ce qu'un blanc parce que
guillaume d'orange
il ya vraiment des toutes les idées que
moi je capable d'avoir x 1000 c puis en
plus toutes les idées que moi je
penserai jamais dit il ya des dix avis à
la guitare si comme moi j'ai j'ai
délaissé un peu lecteurs puis j'ai
commencé à écrire des chansons puis
apprendre des autres instruments puis
des arrangements puis de l'engineering
le mix lui en parallèle il continuait à
être forte sur les guitares encore
aujourd'hui t il pratiqua tout les jours
picchi total à l'insu de policiers et
autant à l'école à nouveau à l'affût des
nouvelles sonorités le nouveau
guitariste de telles baisses de keats
entendu plus aguerris totti est
incroyable lui m'inspire c'est quand il
passe chez nous souvent l'autre il ya
peut-être la moitié du disque il ya des
trucs que je suis bien contente comme
sont sortis cité en deux jours avec moi
qui fait toute la qui détourne que je me
dis que ça prendrait un x factor un
épais que j'ai pas dans mon garde-manger
fait que jacques désengage du monde pour
soi c'est jean hinglo que j'engage pour
faire la programmation des keyboard de
descendre design qui va mal avec des
sons que j'aurais jamais pensé que
guillaume doiron qui fait des guitares
ambiante et auquel j'aurais jamais pensé
puis moi ça renouvelle mon enthousiasme
à ma propre musique tes défauts quand tu
travailles sur un abandon pendant des
mois
en fin de course du quinté support de
mixer l'album a été carrée d'entendre
les tout-petits te demande s'ils sont
bonnes juste partie de 30 ans du avoir
quelqu'un qui va venir ajoute une petite
épices inattendue par dessus ça
renouvelle mon enthousiasme fait que
quand j'arrive dans le stade de mixage
le stade puis le stade de mastering sont
les deux derniers stades de production
d'albums mais là tout d'un coup comme
content de réentendre layton aimerait
des mots d antan de la même façon c'est
de regarder objectivité et puis un recul
justement s'en détournent peut-être trop
entendu c'est un set of mathy je pense
que c'est une de mes forces l'homme et
aussitôt après des années t nous avons
de marie mais la plupart des tonnes il y
avait absolument personne d'autre sur
les tantes qui depuis ce temps-là
j'engage de plus en plus de monde c'est
pour surtout pour moi dit il je sais que
je pourrais aller faire moi-même pi et
jamais personne qui s'en est plaint mais
moi j'ai envie d'avoir envie de
l'écouter
d'ailleurs tu as vu aussi d'apprendre
des demandes le dira c'est pourtant tout
seul aussi c'est que d'apprendre 4 avril
est ce que est ce que ce travail des
fois à partir d'un texte
oui ça arrive ça arrive oui j'aime
vraiment ça faire ça mais ton petit des
exemples pour est ce que parce que ça
semble pas être le tango tous ces singes
et c'est drôle quand j'ai commencé de
même quand j'ai commencé crédit tout je
faisais tout le texte d'un premier quai
puis est ce que tu es excuse moi ce que
non il relance la question est est-ce
que tu quand écrivait-on texte
est-ce que tu écrivais avec en tête une
sonorité
pas vraiment non dangereux un texte
comme comme moyen d'expression
exactement tel texte exactement je sais
qu'il ya une certaine rythmique de danse
mais c'est très limitatif comme approche
comme je disais tantôt les limites sont
vraiment un bon outil pour pour diriger
la créativité fait que je te dirais que
c'est moins courant maintenant parce que
je coécris souvent avec l'artiste
j'essaie de laisser l'opportunité à
l'artiste de de données sont ses
émotions en premier avec je vais écrire
mélodies musique puis qu'est-ce que ça
inspire à l'artiste de quoi il veut
parler c'est effectivement l'artiste va
voir un titre va avoir une coupe de
phrases puis on va partir de ça pour
consulter le texte ensemble c'est un peu
plus facile comme sur piste sata sûr
d'avoir une chanson qui va coller à la
peau de l'artiste encore plus mais ce
dernier album de ludovic qui va paraître
au mois de février
la première ton du disque qui s'appelle
bonsoir solitude c'est un texte qui nous
a été envoyé par nelson minville
qui est un parolier hallucinant qui a
écrit plus d être n'importe qui d'autre
puis le texte c'était incroyable puis
écoute je pense à nous au prix mois plus
des constatations un full text on a
capoté puis on a fait la musique en tout
la maladie les accords 700 nits et c'est
comme un cadeau du ciel parce que les
textes souvent la chose qui prend le
plus de temps
puis je ne peux pas faire de compromis
la piste est moins intuitif écrire un
texte qu une musique une musique soit
avoir une mélodie pop dante est pas une
quittance fait deux accords pikine a
coûté participer mais un texte c'est un
côté un peu plus cérébral be tu peux pas
faire de compromis puis c'est difficile
en france est encore plus difficile de
faire de la bonne musique pop en anglais
entre eux en anglais tu peux la sonorité
des mots fait que tu peux dire un peu
n'importe quoi pis c'est c'était leur
cap ça sonne bien en français c'est
toujours un peu plus difficile faire de
la musique pop justement avec marie-mai
ou avec d'autres artistes
est-ce que ça a été des forêts des
espèces de carter qui comment qu'on fait
la musique pop en français
pis que ça sonne bien mais que ce soit
pour deezer ou quétaine ou quoi que ce
soit mais ça se peut que ça a déjà
souvent internautes et je peux bon juge
pour ça mais faut qu'ils aient à
l'intuition mais une bonne façon de la
faire c'est de faire la maquette en
anglais ok puis après soeur de trouver
un texte en français qui sonne aussi
bien que la maquette en anglais c'est
comme si ça met la barre haute au niveau
sonorités pas parce que la musique en
anglais ses nerfs que la musique en
français mais ça sonne plus facilement
bien c'est juste une question phonétique
tout probablement fait que ça c'est une
bonne façon de le faire puisque c'est
juste une question de travailler jusqu'à
ce qu'elles soient absolument certain
que atteint le maximum de ce que je
pouvais faire
mais c'est off c'est la sphère la plus
difficile puis c'est souvent ce qui fait
que ça va te prendre six mois faire
l'album plutôt que quatre mois c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas toutes les textes
n'ont pas toutes les textes on peut
faire des frontex de trois fois quatre
fois je faisais le ménage demi fondeurs
de ludovic aujourd'hui là parce que j'ai
remis l'album cette semaine puis j'ai
déjà des chansons que j'ai six textes en
français
c'est le sixième que finalement
un qui a fait la cote c'est pas parce
que c'est de la haute poésie
nécessairement ça peut être super simple
puis super accessible mais faut que ce
soit juste une question de son offre que
ce juste pour que ça sonne bien faut que
ce soit et le 15 il faut que ce soit
accessible il ya un paquet de cible il
faut atteindre à mon sens que ce soit
efficace que ça marche puis que ce soit
c'est des fois tu reçois un texte qui
est super mais fait pas avec l'artiste
si tu fermes les yeux et imaginez
l'artiste dire un mot aux petits
pensionnés pasmal un bon exemple s'est
dit d'avis que c'est une personne super
intelligent que là il ya super
conversation pis mais c'est quand même
un doute dans vingtaine qui fait la
musique pas signaux lancés ne peut pas
utiliser le même vocabulaire que dans
une zone d'intérêt de saint-pierre cinq
noms kiki quelqu'un de beaucoup plus
cérébral puis de beaucoup plus
intellectuelle pi souvent ingrid a écrit
deux chansons sur premier album de
ludovic est une chanson sur le dernier
album de ludovic il ya des mots que je
dis donc c'est quoi ça si moi je
trouvais de google
c'est sûr que les fans de ludovic il y
en a une grande partie qui va pas
connaître le maul 57 en piqué s'est pas
de sous-estimer les femmes essaient de
comprendre à qui tu t'adresses pis
ludovic c'est une de ses forces
y compris comprend son public pis il
fait avec son public de façon naturelle
puisque c'est une des affaires qui le
plus importante c'est même pas de
comprendre son public des projets de
comprends ton public mais il faut que ce
que tu as à dire sans ligne avec ce que
ton public potentiel ont envie
d'entendre de façon naturelle puis les
meilleurs artistes y comprennent ça
instinctivement sais je rencontre
souvent des artistes un moment donné un
artiste pop que je n'aimerais pas qui a
fait un album un album vraiment gauche
de gauche c'était incroyablement bon
mais je me rappelle avoir dit à
l'artiste qui me demandait mon avis tu
es j'ai dis c'était quoi jeu
obligé de te dire que je pense pas que
tu vas fort est avec ça parce que les
gens qui écoutent ce style de musique là
habituellement ils vont pas acheter un
album de toi parce qu'ils y ont déjà
leur idée préconçue de ce que toi tu
représentes culturellement c'est c'est
comme si je sais pas
marie-mai décidé de faire un album à la
marie pierre arthur - je faisais les
fans de marie pierre arthur ils vont pas
acheter un album de marie mai en général
préfèrent une palette de marie-mai votre
ip sûr ils vont partir là dessus puis
même si marie mai faisait un album un
milliard de fois meilleur qui ariane
moffatt qui marie pierre arthur king
près de saint pierre dans le même style
les fans de ces artistes là c'est
souvent pas défendre de marie-mai fait
que ça donne pas grand chose est sûre ce
sera [ __ ] au complet le temps changer
d'ici à changer d'image changé toujours
c'est difficile ça peut être fait c'est
fait de façon authentique peu
incohérente
il ya des artistes qui ont réussi comme
alanis morissette dans les années 90
c'est au début des années 90 enfin 80
faisaient des albums hyper pop à la
britney spears et puis elle réussit
vraiment en faire un 180 degrés mais à
la sortie un des meilleurs albums des 30
dernières années fait si tu fais là pour
qu'ils fassent ce soit bon faut que ce
soit il faut pas que ce soit bon faut
que ce soit génial faut que ce soit
indéniablement génial c'est comme
vraiment renverser la vapeur pour
renverser le courant de façon complète
il faut que tu arrives
avec quelque chose de complètement
excuse toi en tant qu real si on associe
pi2 surtout travaillé sur des projets
plus peuple telle avec bourjois
marie-mai mardi prix aurait-il goûteux
lancer dans un projet fou champ gauche
ou d'un étudiant se sait juste pas pour
moi ben moi j'aime tellement de styles
différents que je sais très bien que
j'ai tout son stock lé ouais c pourrait
le faire un album et peuple vous faire
un album
il perd champ gauche fox suis pas mais
je comprends pourquoi ces artistes là
m'appelleront pas ouais mais si on voit
le chiffre et oui absolument
absolument c'est mais je comprends quand
même d'un point de vue marketing d'un
point de vue name dropping puis d'un
point de vue cohésion pourquoi en
général fortement de la qui m'appelle
c'est fichu ben correct je pense pas
qu'il ya beaucoup de monde qui pense que
ce parce que tu voudrais pas peut-être
pourrez-vous ouais ouais
absolument et encore une fois faut
accepter le principe de roussillon on
met des gens dans des boîtes
je sais moi non plus j'appellerais pas
probable j'appellerais pas nécessaire
que me tire le coyote pour faire son
prochain album
mais non mais j'appellerais pas non plus
les soeurs bulli pour écrire une chanson
pour le nouvel album de marc dupré
même si à pourrait prêt pourrait
probablement faire un incroyable c'est
juste que c'est comme poteau france
corse et on met les gens dans une boîte
puis j'essaie quand même de mes forces
et à mélanger les effluves des fois puis
faire des espèces de rencontres
improbables ce fort par exemple ouais
mais blake et clinton pour ludovic
bourgeois maintenant mais le pire c'est
qu'on l'attend avec une crête saint
pierre qui va qui a écrit de ton du
premier album de l'ue devaient compter
les 2 tonnes des extraits qui ont été
les deux tons numéro un bis ça a été il
ya encore une fois je donne les crédits
à vers une caisse s'élevait à l'époque
qui a eu comme staff lâche là puis je me
donne le crédit d'avoir fait comme faut
qu'on laissait puis finalement ça a été
super concluant fait qu'il ya plein
d'avoir comme ceux qui se font de temps
en temps aussi des belles surprises
mais je comprends quand même pourquoi je
dirais
on met les gens dans des bois de fait ne
faut pas s'effaroucher quand les gens
nous mêmes dans des mois mais des fois
des fois c'est genre de mix et bris de
l'os
ça sonne faux ça paraît si je me
rappelle on en parlait justement un
petit peu plus tôt avec roxane bruno
l'équité qui étaient venus sur le
podcast pierre on parlait de jean marc
couture jean marc suret sur son premier
album je posterai et raillé la tune oui
j'ai fait une tournée il ya invité à
tourner avec c'était écrit par daniel
bélanger
oui c'était les temps dit ouais c'était
ton désir puis jean-marc sur moi je t'ai
tout tu le connaissais à 20 mois j'avais
rencontré une fois je connaissais le
personnage on l'avait vu à star académie
était au coeur d'un petit comme pas
ouvert tant que sur ses émotions
homme de peu de mots un homme de peu de
mots je me rappellerai toujours la
première phrase de ce téléthon désert
qui était le ciel est bleu comme je me
sens vieux à noircir mes nuits blanches
pileux mais j'entends ça c'est comme
c'est daniel bélanger qui soldes géantes
couture c'est une phrase de daniel
bélanger le clairement son univers
clairement ça lui appartient de type le
problème est que c'est fait de demander
mg on a besoin d'une toune des crises et
une pour jean lacouture plus et comme tu
entends sup cnc palais jean marc je
voulais consommer ou type si c'est
encore moins le daniel bélanger que je
voulais consommer s'est fixé comme un
hybride qui m'étonne pas mais li na vi a
peut-être lever cette taille là puisque
ça a été un croc et fait encore une fois
tiré le plafond de quelqu'un et le plan
d'eau dit il ya un moment donné
christopher white qui est un auteur
compositeur canadien incroyable écrit
black velvet dans la nommèrent en trop
qui est un succès internationaux raté
puis j'ai écrit plein j'ai eu la chance
d'écrire clinton avec lui puis à un
moment donné je me rappelle que je me
rappelle pas en état en charpie il y
avait une tonne qui joua piges
j'ai pitié sur la tnt c'est la mienne
non il m'a dit est maudit peut-être
raison mais tu peux pas top tu peux pas
destinée avec le succès en guise excess
des voix puis ça a changé ma vie cette
phrase de parcieux un moment donné c'est
facile de tomber dans le snobisme a pu
tomber dans le rouge aurait pas fait
tout ça ben c'est tellement plate ce
tournoi je peux pas croire que du monde
comme ça ces squats a pas besoin de
croire qu'ils se demandent quelle sauce
il ya déjà du monde
les faits étant pas demander ton avis et
puis je pense que c'est une bonne façon
de d'approcher la critique de dire c'est
quoi ces mêmes mots qui décide c'est les
gens qui détermine s'il ya john may à un
moment donné qui donnait une conférence
à je pense à berkeley c'est une
université à boston le programme musical
est vraiment un super reconnu lui a
étudié à bhl clé puis donner un espèce
de conférences à brûler devant les
étudiants en musique puis il dit lever
votre main ceux d'entre vous qui pensent
que vous avez une meilleure oreille que
la personne moyenne qui écoutent la
radio c'est évidemment tout des
musiciens pros en démission qui a été
acceptée à berck ligue 1 avec sept
autres des virtuoses puis des gens qui
ont un talent fou il ya plus qu à
l'amortissement qui se lève la main puis
lui dit vous êtes tous dans le champ
vielles personnes de nous kiki meilleure
oreille que le public parce que c'est
eux qui décident
qu'est ce qui est bon nous on peut
décider qu'on veut rajouter 83 à corbie
50000 changement de tempo plus de
tonalité dans notre taux de modulation
pu faire ça super intelligent puisque
par virtuoz mais si le public en général
veut pas l'entendre c'est aux autres qui
décide c'est leur oreille qui le jugent
finale avec moment une petite web
n'importe qui qui est le moindrement
impliqué dans professionnellement en
musique on est sujet au jugement
du citoyen moyen qui écoutent la radio
dans son char puis moi je trouve que
c'est une bonne façon de garder une
humilité c'est bon pour la santé de
penser comme ça mais c'est vraiment
parler d'eux at elle dit comment ça se
passe mais en dessous tu as tout la
couche qu'on voit poser l'iphone c'est
qu'ils font merci bien
j'ai dit j'ai des amis qui est en fait
j'étais quittons instagram aux gens que
je connais un peu plus j'ai vu le visage
qu'ils connaissaient mes amis a indiqué
rayons de jouets qui me chasser oui puis
lui bastad à fait logique je vais
ailleurs je pensais justement écrire à
frites pour les vidéos par mois 10
invite les squelettes des histoires
incroyables du mahdi il m'a dit
ségo le sait les musiciens les plus
préparés que j'ai vu de ma vie
ah oui il m'a dit allez sa guise on
aurait dit qu'il avait fait 100 fois dit
harvey il connaissait toutes les
tournées crise et bac avec une assurance
d'un gars qui chante et son bac sans
fois le train - mais c'est parce que
obama eut le guitariste que je
remplaçais dans une machine de malades
écrit layton avec rémi c'est moi c'est
encore une fois la trampoline tu veux
servir l'artiste veut aider l'artiste a
raconté son histoire
c'est vraiment un jeu s'appuie aussi le
fait que j'ai une réputation qu'elle va
devoir de prendre la geek pour acquitter
puis pipe aussi rémi chassé ses
incroyables sa musique ni pitié je sais
c'est pas super payant de dire je vais
apprendre un choc du show confère une
fois il faut faire une fois tu mets moi
j'avais j'ai été à au lancement de
l'album de rim chasse et j'avais chier à
terre ouais j'ai fait comme qui s et ça
ça craint maintenant c'est aussi bon que
les foo fighters puisqu'elle n'importe
quoi d'autre qui me fait triper de ce
qui vient des états unis puis en
angleterre
je rappelle j avais écrites et je
t'attends lancement tu ne connais pas
mais j'ai pas nîmes en 2 minutes puis
quand il m'a appelé pour 10
pour la parole à pour le show j'ai fait
comme un oui j'ai dit oui tout de suite
apprécié j'écoutais l'étude j'ai fait
comme ok bah quoi je me sens embarqués
parce que justement il ya des back
vocals tout le long des rives les
guitares hyper hyper compliqué mais
quand même assez compliqué syncopé avec
des rythmiques quand même qu'il faut que
j'écrive qui ont rien à voir avec ce tee
shirts il faut que chante
écoutez je me suis payé il ya vraiment
fallu je suis toujours préparé sauf que
le haut lieu que ça me prend deux jours
de monter les choses ça m'a pris une
semaine au complet pratique est vraiment
je voulais pas je voulais faire bonne
figure mais je voulais surtout que la
chose soit pas significativement moins
bon que quand c'est cuba qui te fait
libère ses des grosses chaussures à
chausser les factures vraiment ça je
suis content que c'est comme ça que ça a
été perçu ce que moi je dis pas que
c'était parfait là mais c'était vraiment
fun notice est un chanteur incroyable et
une sont hallucinantes son band
centaines de feux titre je veux pas être
le maillon le maillon faible de
l'équation
non je comprends bien des nappages
d'arriver sur la première chose après a
pris sur le fait et aussi solide
japonais merci on a fait des pas de
géant a donné un million c'est la
raquette koné a qui ont pesé le plus
cool des plus cool de gaulle je pense
qu'on était avec sa mamma mia
je sais je sais puis
que dit bientôt suspense à travailler
ensemble a pas longtemps je pense oui
oui on travaille
aussitôt qu'on peut on travaille
ensemble il est tellement fin que le
mental en tissu teint
c'est une machine au pianiste de vinyle
est un pianiste un arrangeur il ya des
arrangements orchestrale incroyable avec
302 logic pro le fou furieux mais maudit
il me dirait sagesse et gueulait c'est
l'ego le plus
focus sur son travail ti cats travail
c'est comme il n'ya pas de différence
marques primées mythe y est tellement
cave grand sentiment de laisser mon
studio on veut recevoir marc dupré a
fait quoi il ya tellement vite sur les
jobs sont rien dire il m'a menti cela
limite à terme il ya dans toute l'italie
armand d'année moi j'ai dans mon triplex
de chicago n'a changé ce sujet il s'est
tapé que tout les compteurs diderot sont
dans mon unité à moi hambourg puis
maintenant c'est des compteurs
intelligents
depuis quelques années c'est à dire que
bon les chiffes se transmettent par
cellulaire
pourquoi mais avant fallait quelqu'un
diderot qui venait avec les trois mois
pour venir prendre en note les chiefs et
comptant un moment donné je suis en
train de travailler son album de marc du
prime ça ça n'apporte pas un monsieur
qui qui venait écoute le monsieur qui a
été là pendant un gros 35 secondes puis
il ya marc qui a tout eu le temps de
capter son langage corporel puis sa
sonorité de woippy son accent keaton
puis a passé le reste de l'après-midi
habilité imiter les godillots le livre
d'isaïe vais la prendre c'est que c'est
le pire pour l'esprit de la marque
imiterait il disait justement dit est
tellement concentré peut-être tellement
intense en nommant un ordi je pourrais
pas de limites et moi même le mât par
aman que c'est des fois je vais fraport
ce mon clavier de quelqu'un je peux si
je pèse sur ce top en même temps qu'un
groupe d'hommes dans tonnes ouais je
vois passer plus fort suspect ce bar
juste parce que c'est sur un dans bild
en tout cas ce qu'elle voit juste assez
intense quand
ça doit expliquer pourquoi deux capables
de faire ça aussi de façon aussi
productive - tu n'es pas comme comment
si j'imagine que tu trouves pas boiseur
produits frais ont fait sur facebook
quand tu t'entraînes non non non non non
parce que je pense que c'est vraiment
une question de momentum puis j'essaie
de garder le momentum pour moi même mais
pour l'artiste ou cityville je me rends
compte que l'artiste ait stimulé par
cette espèce d'efficacité là parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'artistes sont habitués au
travail de studio que tout et l'on sait
pital ingénieurs de l'assistant génial
réalisateur et à la grosse console puis
l'on va essayer 14 micro voir laquelle
microsoft le milieu puis on vacille 14
pipe des artistes sont souvent de nature
impatiente d'y impulser fpi spontanée be
c'est plate pour un artiste est assis
sur un divan pendant que tu as 14 guide
qui tombe dépit tante qui je me suis
souvent fait dire parce que moi j'ai pas
vraiment vécu ça commencé de travailler
dans un gros studio avec douze personnes
qui travaillent en même tant pis qui
font chacun leur cette partie du travail
si j'ai toujours travaillé presque seul
en studio puis je m'occupe de tout fait
que les artistes qui ont aussi connu le
côté un petit peu plus plat plan dette
en studio avec un processus plus
laborieux ils m'ont souvent commenté
sera quel point c'est le fun c'est
stimulant de d'être dans un
environnement où tout se passe
rapidement des petits pas su plus rapide
que les autres mais c'est comme si j'ai
j'ai stoppé mon studio d'enregistrement
pour avec les et l'équipement que je
connais que j'ai envie d'utiliser
brancher tout en branle tout et tout
temps branché pour être utilisé comme ça
les emplois du temps sont déjà marquées
des instruments sont toutes accordées
sont optionnelles la drôme et là il est
déjà marqué j'ai un mépris en favori du
boîtier j'en ai un pour la voix qui tout
le temps tu branché avec le micro qui
est dans le book j'en un deuxième qui
est branché avec le micro qui est juste
à côté de nous autres et qui si on prend
le micro juste branche très une idée
vite fait si c'étaient les bonnes
paroles de l'idée a été bien chanter
avait déjà enregistré pour pouvoir la
garder son album fait que c'est vraiment
un processus qui est fait pour être
efficace
à cause de ma propre impatients
finalement moi je n'ai pas envie
d'enregistrer une maquette d'après soit
deux mois plus tard enregistre une vraie
version finale de la tonne alors que
c'est moi qui fait tout mais faire comme
du monde je suis calme en fait que c'est
un peu seul un efficacité qui est un peu
produits produits de mon impatience
est ce que est ce que tu acceptes un peu
les imperfections dans ton travail
j'ai de la misère avec ça ouais ouais
j'ai de la misère avec ça et au canyon
drac qui est pas donné à 100% parfait je
la refais où je le disais tout une voix
qui est un peu fausse je vois la tune et
des fois j'aurais peut-être intérêt à
lâcher prise
j'essaie de le faire dès fois je réussis
mais le problème c'est qu'il faudrait
que je délègue en plus puis les budgets
sont de plus en plus petit les budgets
d'albums fait peut-être plus ça va moins
je rêve d'argent à donner à d'autres
mondes
je finis par faire un peu tout moi même
mes derniers albums de ludovic j'ai
réussi à lâcher prise un petit peu puis
à être un petit peu moins
perfectionniste sur certaines europe
j'ai l'impression que ça respire un peu
plus situe mieux ce type au mieux je
pense que ça change pas grand chose
parce que encore une fois si je pense
que si la chanson est là la chanson est
bonne ça répète enregistré vraiment
moins bien ou vraiment mieux pis à leur
poche changer le succès de la chanson il
ya longtemps que c'est pas une
imperfection ou créés c'est justement
paul l est pas haifa et le tire vraiment
folle et wallis et les chips ou
piquionne beauté là dedans c'est souvent
le premier à reconnaître cette boule
téloche of the world mais mais je pense
que faut que ce soit fait d'emblée
exemple souvent ce qu'on a en tant qu on
entend des chansons des enregistrements
qui ont été faits qui sont un petit peu
plus lac
ouais c'est souvent un band qui jouent
en même temps dans le studio
tout le monde joue en même temps puis
ils vont chanter là ils vont faire la
toon pardon
4 5 x 6 x peu importe puis après ça ils
vont écouter puis vont prendre la
meilleure prise puis ça va être sur la
tonne puis il ya une beauté là dedans
mais je pense que faut que ce soit fait
tout le monde en même temps tu dis si un
client qui se trompent
un petit plus qui fait notre un petit
peu moins moins franches ou moins
précisément c'est compensé par le fait
que tout le monde est tellement en même
temps puis tout le monde se suit puis un
espèce de l'imperfection qui respire oui
ça accélère un peu dans le refrain mais
tout le monde accélère un peu en même
temps fait que ça qu'on pensait alors
que dans un optique plus pop
la plupart des albums pop sont fait
vraiment piste par piste est
l'instrument ainsi emprunt soit infecté
tu commences par peut-être une traque
guitare voix qui qui qui sert de guide
pour satisfaire la batterie quito
métronome piqué vraiment apprécié ce
fait la base miss la base est un peu et
pas vraiment est le drummer il va pas
compenser dans le refrain si le passé
s'accélère le drame aurait déjà partie
sa draghi fait il faut que la police est
conforme à ce qui a été enregistré
d'avant ce fait qui a pu vraiment place
à à l'erreur ou l'espèce d'imperfections
peu l'espèce de fluctuation dans le beat
avec ça donne des enregistrements qui
sont plus précis qui sont plus clean qui
sont plus francs mais qui sont peut-être
un petit peu moins organique
je pense qu'il ya des musiques qui se
prête à un approche un peu plus la queue
puis des musiques qui ont besoin de te
revois les dents face comme la tonne de
briques pitié la plupart des chansons
qui joue à la radio qui font des hits cd
des chansons qui ont été faites de façon
plus précise l'extérieur avec une tonne
dans le même style mais qui était fait
un peu plus lac ça a tendance à sonner
amateurs alors que si tu arrives avec
une chanson folk plusieurs ganic mais
qui a été fait de façon très rigide à la
pop
quand ça situe la compare avec des
chansons du même style mais qui ont été
faites avec une approche plus organique
le tout d'un coup ça sensitif
ouais c'est vraiment tout le temps de
s'y trouver la meilleure façon
de représenter de l'artiste puis sa
chanson dans le contexte en sachant ça
va jouer ou qui qui qui va écouter ce
qu'ils voient et mais c'est qui qui va
avoir envie de l'entente se sait qu'il
public le site au public les coûts de
quoi d'autres loisirs si tu fais une
chanson pour un public qui écoutent du
edge shiren puits du champ de mendez
mais tu l'as tu enregistres pour un
public qui écoutent du du bon iver
il ya un genre de manque de cohérence
faut toujours garder tout ça à l'esprit
de ce fait que c'est pas une question de
se sentent comme dit fred st-gelais
mais c'est sûr qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'artistes qui m'appelle parce que j'ai
fait plein de gros hits pop avec des
artistes pop qui m'appelle puis on va
continuer à faire des chansons dans ce
style là puis j'ai fait un album et
havlat 2 en pis tout s'est doté cette
processus là a été ignoré complètement
puis on l'a fait vraiment comme un vrai
album métal puis ça c'est comme un vrai
album métal mais je mettrais pas un
album de vie bourgeois patiemment
cellphone l'émission à moi apprécie
vraiment les quais insight ren d'année
en famille bon ben je suis vieux
ça sert à quelque chose d'autre pour
finir si on regarde le classement mais
tu nous parler depuis une heure et demie
de pressage et le musicien mais
fressange l'élu menti soit fondement par
un printemps chez qui des dernières
années tu as vécu quand même plusieurs
changements à béton ouais
ap si mes pieds je veux pas d'un portage
quoi que ce soit m c'est là toute
palette de saveurs grand voyage trois
points puis à ton retour je pense que
tout est reparti de seuls quelque chose
comme ça ce petit nom je pense que je
suis parti après notre séparation c'est
ça ouais mais qui en fait premièrement
pour la question qu'est ce qui a motivé
le premier voyage qu'est ce qui motive
et le deuxième le premier voyage je
pense que c'est une tentative de
devoir citer notre couple est encore
viable car ce qui est en dehors de tout
le reste à d'autres leur est lancé mais
on commençait à sentir à certaines
difficultés et puis on a décidé de
forcer comme un espèce de je pense une
tentative de bloquer les fils qui était
qui et qui est arrachée 2 c'est pis à
l'a manifestement pas marché mais
c'était incroyable comme voyage puis ça
a changé ma vie
en fait ça me préparais à mon ma
deuxième du monde après marie mai il
avait préparé par pendant ses appuis ça
le planter dans ma tête est depuis dans
ma façon de vivre vraiment tout le côté
minimaliste puis simplicité pis ça là
aussi d'une façon contribué à creuser le
fossat elle et moi
malgré tout les deux trips et pendant le
voyage moi je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais fait pas mal le tour du globe
si j'avais fait pas mal de tours de
travailler 17 heures par jour sept jours
sur sept points
elle note si on avait une dizaine
d'années de différence quand même
l'outil je veux dire à l'époque elle
avait trois ans j'avais 40 puis j'avais
10 ans d'avancé sur l aile quand on a
commencé à travailler fort bien habile
de sa carrière me faisais déjà de dix
ans que j'étais là dedans 15 heures par
jour puis ces jours sur sept au fait que
fait ce voyage malgré le fait que ça a
été super sale a quand même mis en
lumière certaines différences au niveau
de notre parcours puis ça nous a
confirmé qu on ne peut être plus à ma
place picquenot nos envies pineau but
pineau notre prochaine étape n'était pas
la main un petit sa prochaine étape
était différent de mes prochaines étapes
a envie de continuer et puis vraiment
aller de l'avant avec d'autres albums
puis grosse carrière moi j'avais envie
de commencer à profiter un peu de ce que
j'avais smid récolté un peu ce que
j'avais six mètres j'avais le moyen
petit arrive à 40,2 en petit é il y en
as planète l'inde
j'ai juste vu là un pour cent de cette
lettre je peux tu as voyages et plus je
peux tu découvrir autre chose que ça
apprendre l'espagnol je peux tu faire
mon cours de plongée sous-marine je peux
tu allais faire du vélo sera courtois
josiane importe quoi
mme amhis vivre pour moi c'est rendu là
elle était pas rendu les hôpitaux je
vous apprends un million d'autres
raisons fait quand on s'est séparés
mouchetés c'est ce qui a vraiment
confirmé que j'avais mon instit voyage
sud de cette ville ' pas que ce n'était
pas une belle ville à l'éthique que
j'avais vraiment envie de vivre autre
chose c'est que la première fois que
j'ai fait ce que j'ai tout vendu puis
j'ai sacrément quand dans ces j'ai
racheté une roulotte comme celle qu'on
avait envie de faire notre trip gdg
dedans pendant deux ans sans écouter de
musique sans jouer du temps quand je
recommence à jouer au barça mais pendjab
j'étais comme un débutant comme
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais joué de guitare
me tuer transplante le cerveau d'un
guitariste aurait fait ch avec ou mettre
mes doigts mais ça faisait mal ans akram
un même projet je suis revenu j'ai
commencé à écrire des tonnes pour
l'album de ludovic bour joué depuis son
premier album c'est le premier projet
que j'ai fait qu'achever nul
j'avais mal à la main par jouer de la
guitare je me sentais comme un instit
débitage petit mais c'est cette espèce
de poser leurs que confirmer que j'aurai
encore quelque chose à dire que j'avais
encore des idées puis avait encore envie
d'être créatif tgt deux ans sans même
écouter de la musique
or je vais de 25000 km dans six langues
votre podcast
j'écoutais rien j'écoute la rue les
leçons des pneus sur nère sur la sfac
micro d'i am and is ses revenus tout
seul set en ville est créé pour dams et
non pas en doute
patrick bourgeois m'appeler qui
modifiait dans le désert le jeu montrant
une photo de vie des photos pendant
qu'on parle parce que tu es plein
d'histoires j'ai regardé celui de kim
c'est par l'idh
j'avais un million d' image de l avec
bien dessus sur scène ça va être encore
plus de travailleurs mais ya pas de
bourgeois ouais le devis qui venait de
gagner la voix mouchetés dans le désert
je vais pas terrible j'avais j'aime pas
j'avoue qu'une idylle mais ludovic
venait de gagner la voix patrick voulait
que je l'aide à réaliser l'album de son
pote
mais on savait que patrick mêmes été
malades puis dans ma tête j'avais pas
envie de faire de musique
j'avais envie d'aider un ami malade
c'était vraiment ça je revenais je dis
ok je vais revenir cet été puis je vais
voir ma famille inquiète puis je vois et
et patrick à faire l'album de son fils
parce que c'est mon amitié m'a raté
c'est vraiment ça mais survenue pis
c'est en le faisant que je me suis rendu
compte que je le fais que j'avais envie
peut-être de recommencer mais j'ai
commencé mais j'ai recommencé mollo n'a
rien à voir ce que je faisais avant
on était partis combien de temps tu est
finalement plus ou moins deux ans yes
man 2
ouais ouais c'est pour ça qu'on
entendrait plus parler
ben oui et puis en même temps c'est une
des grosses raison pour qu'on en
entendait parler il y en a plein des
réalisateurs des auteurs compositeurs
qui font des hits qui fondent et on
s'est passé super travail puis on sait
pas s'ils quittent ces chaussures c'est
un métier qui par défaut et dans l'ombre
s'est demandé si tu marine vedette tente
et je vais en entendre parler tout apple
fait que c'est plus pour ça je pense pas
que je suis pas connu mon nom il pas
plus connu que les autres réalisateurs
parce que je suis meilleur parce que
j'ai fait du meilleur travail que les
autres réalisateurs mais parce que j'ai
été
c'est mémé au city j'ai la chance de
développer des vues que je conjugue co
écrit les chansons avec les artistes
les artistes ont en plus tendance à
parler de mon entrevue c'est parce que
la façon dont je travaille c'est que
l'artiste est tout seul avec moi pendant
plusieurs mois en studio puis ont une
écriture des chansons ensemble et on
enregistre depuis il me vois faire tous
les instruments fait que c'est sûr que
je suis responsable d'une certaine
partie du travail fait qu' on est en
plus tendance à un homme est mon nom
c'est marc qui m'a souvent donner
beaucoup de crédit puis détaché au sipi
mari mais aussi tu es venu d'afrique
beaucoup
betv aussi je les accompagne souvent
spectacle ça contribue un peu à faire
circuler mon nom mais c'est surtout
parce que j'ai déjà ma mari mais qu'elle
monte ça ça va mon nom on s'entend dans
des quintés fac intervenus du voyage le
ca a été acquis finalement ce que je
faisais avant place
webb est à recommencer finalement j'ai
commencé mon lot parce que j'avais
repris le bit que ta vie non j'ai fait
ludovic puis je suis parti après le jour
partie dans l'ouest puis j'ai passé
l'hiver dans l'ouest est survenu l'été
suivant j'ai fait la garde
la course des trucs qui est comme le
deuxième film de la guerre des tuques
j'écris un paquet de chansons puis je
réalise un paquet de chansons pour ça
bien sûr partie c'est je fais je fais ça
pas mal et je reviens l'été et je fais
un disque ou un projet puis fait des
shows des fois vous avec un artiste
routier puis à pression j'en reparle
j'essaie de trouver un équilibre le
personnellement béton ça lui équilibrées
du temps mieux en général qui met en
quatre avec 14 heures par jour à
l'époque ben c'est sûr mais en même
temps je regrette pas de l'avoir fait
parce que ça a été nécessaire pour
moitié
premièrement pour pour apprendre ce que
j'avais besoin d'apprendre pour créer ce
que j'avais besoin de créer puis aussi
même d'un point de vue financier c'est
la raison pourquoi je peux me permettre
aujourd'hui de travailler six mois par
année c'est que j'ai travaillé comme un
as tu une maniaque pendant pendant tout
ce temps là tu sais ce que tu es 8 et 45
livres sur comment optimiser ses actifs
changerait rien pour vous le monde m'a
dit que ça finisse a vraiment pas bien
fini avec marie-mai haïti mais je veux
tu peux focus sur le fait que ça
vraiment pas bien fini avec marie mai
mais tu peux aussi focus et sur le fait
que sur les onze ans qu'on est ensemble
il ya eu neuf ans incroyable dans un
espèce de feddal tweet de deux ans comme
toutes les communes de la cc jamais le
fun mais c'est rock que tu fais comme
c'était très mal fans de divorce
en sommes arrivés à leurs fins
effectivement aujourd'hui tu vois ça
comme un changement positif
oui c'est tout les changements tous les
changements sont positifs d'une certaine
façon si tu donnes assez de temps pour
gagner la perspective nécessaire mais ça
va super bien dans ma vie et j'ai pas de
je suis content de pas avoir tombé dans
le la vengeance vis dans le drame puis
les médiums salissage c'est avec
marie-mai beyoncé jamais revu mots de
marie mai mais on sait qu'une fois de
temps en temps en piste de nico lui
pisser georgie souhaite que ça marche
c'est à faire puis on est tous les deux
super positif le ou vers le haut depuis
les deux ça va bien aux affaires quand
même été dans une relation très
interdépendants
j'ai l'impression à l'époque je pense
que comme souvent ce que non non sinon
je pense que au contraire je pense quand
on oui ans apportait beaucoup mais c'est
je pense qu'à le prouver qu'ils avaient
peu partout besoin de mots pour des
pathologies sais pas ce que je vais en
attendant notre vue je pense que c'est
tout le monde en parle ou qu'elle disait
si je faisais pas de la musique avec
fred ça me ferait pas oui mais oui parce
que je l'avais jamais fait 3 comprend
que je te dis pas que n'importe quel
changement peut peut peut faire peur
mais je faisais elle savait pas qu'il y
avait assez de talent pour pour faire
ces trucs avec quelqu'un d'autre même où
je savais que j'avais l'expérience
nécessaire pour la perspective
nécessaire pour savoir qui avait le
talent pour le faire
et puis moi j'avais déjà fait plein
d'affaires avant et elle fait que moi je
m'inquiétais pas de toute façon même
pendant que je travaillais lequel je
travaille avec d'autres artistes puis ça
marchait bien fait de porter d'autres si
je veux dire il n'y a ni l'autre pense
qu'on dépend des de l'autre pour pour
avancer puis je pense que de la preuve
et blanc affirme de son côté qu'elle
continue sa vie en fait des 10 pires a
fait des shows qui est fait des bébés
qu'est-ce qu'on va falloir bien et le
talent vraiment bien mais moi je suis
folle amoureuse puis j'ai sérieusement
je peux pas demander quoi que ce soit
d'autre part ce serait vraiment greedy
[Rires]
sérieusement je suis tellement dans la
gratitude que tout est une surprise tout
les neuf enfants qu'elle a vus mais en
voici une surprise qui gère l'accueil
puis je le prends pas pour acquis devant
un plan prédéfini des dents
personnellement si j'ai juste envie
d'être en santé et puis de continuer
amoureux puis continue d'avoir la la
famille les amis que j'ai dit c'est une
professionnellement j'ai l'impression
que j'ai fait mais j'ai roulé mais tour
le sexy jeune pour dire ça mais j'en ai
assez fait dramatique tout le reste
c'est du bonus puis j'ai l'impression
que j'ai effectivement plus pour aider
le monde que je trouve donc que pour
moitié
je vous charge et la totale pareil tant
que je vais être capable c'était pas
grave mais mais mais je le fais parce
que ça ne prend quelque chose à faire
j'ai réalisé qu'elle lui la retraite
c'est vraiment overweight je pensais que
j'allais plus jamais travailler vite et
j'avais la possibilité de vivre une vie
simple mais confortables sont
retravaillées mais après un an un an et
demi je me sentais tellement inutile
c'est qu'un petit encore encore des
idées peut-être encore productif est
encore en santé de ne rien faire c'est
un peu quasiment de manquer de respect à
sa propre chance via sa propre
synthétique non utilisés que j'ai encore
le potentiel
plus encore les idées puis j'ai encore
mais je le fais pas comme ces chiens
pour tout le monde qui aime la sec a pas
de la fab qui peuvent pas le faire parce
qu'ils ont la possibilité de la faire
avec l'os génique un bon équilibre
je travaille la moitié de l'année puis
après ça l'autre moitié je travaille moi
mais je voyage pige lippi je continue à
hama brevet de connaissance puis à
développer des sites et des habiletés et
puis faire de nouvelles rencontres
riches pas assis en avant de la tv ou
sur bord de la mer à compter les
poissons qui passent là mais mais
j'essaie de vraiment tu penses que j'ai
trouvé un bon équilibre
c'est parce que si qu'en musique ou
probablement que c'est la même chose
dans plein de domaines
je peux pas décider de travailler trois
jours par semaine parce que si je fais
un disque un artiste
lui est dans le pré lors il faut que son
album sorte à telle date c'est fake -
chacun peut pas nier avec les dead line
des autres fait plutôt que travailler
douze mois par année trois quatre jours
par semaine si trouver un équilibre
comme ça
la façon dont j'ai trouvé que ça
fonctionnait avec mon métier c'est de
travailler vraiment fort dans le pré
leur pendant la moitié de l'année puis
après ça vraiment réduite fait que
souhaiter - rien de plus si je peux
garder le statu quo
je veux je veux aller c'est pour les
hommes on souhaite le statu quo merci
beaucoup merci fred merci boys